bonjour et bienvenue à tous ici au Sénat
pour suivre sur Public Sénat la séance
la dernière séance concernant l'examen
du budget
2011 alors cet après-midi nous en sommes
à l'examen des derniers articles de la
loi de finances sont des articles un
petit peu ftout qu'on appelle les
articles non rattachés mais qui souvent
contiennent un certain nombre de
dispositions fiscales il reste une
quinzaine d'amendements à examiner et
puis tout de suite après viendra un
moment important et qui risque d'être un
moment qui va être faire l'objet d'un
certain nombre d'affrontements
politiques puisque vous le savez le
gouvernement a demandé une nouvelle
délibération avant le vote définitif sur
un article sur un amendement voté par le
Sénat et ça a été confirmé par par
François Fillon ce matin et par le
ministre du Budget françois Barouin cet
après-midi le gouvernement veut
absolument revenir sur une disposition
qui avait été voté par le Sénat il y a
quelques jours et qui vise à remettre à
réintroduire
l'exonération de charg social qui a été
accordée au particulierers employeurs ou
tout du moins une certaine catégorie de
particulier employeurs cette disposition
votée par le Sénat donc contre l'avis du
gouvernement coûterait 4500 million
d'euros et pour François Fillon il n'est
pas question dans l'équation budgétaire
de 2011 de dépenser 1 € de plus donc euh
sur ce point précis le gouvernement a
demandé une autre délibération il y a
d'autres amendements sur lesquels il
n'est pas d'accord avec la version votée
par le Sénat notamment en ce qui
concerne la suppression de la publicité
sur France Télévision puisque le
maintien de la pub en journée a été
décidé par les députés et que le Sénat
veut limiter ce maintien de la pub
c'est-à-dire la situation actuelle dans
la journée à seulement deux ou trois
années supplémentaires voilà alors mais
ça ça fera l'objet de discussion en
commission mixte paritaire la semaine
prochaine entre députés et sénateurs en
revanche sur l'exonération de charge
sociale là le gouvernement veut montrer
de façon très nette qu'il n'entend pas
qu'il y ait un quelconque dérapage dans
les dépenses par rapport à l'équilibre
budgétaire qu'il fait voter dans le
cadre de ce budget 2011 nous suivrons
donc en direct cet après-midi la fin
d'abord de la discussion sur ces
articles non rattachés avec je vous le
disais une une petite quinzaine
d'amendements encore à examiner puis
bien sûr ce moment de discussion qui
s'annonce assez vif 2uxème délibération
demandée par le gouvernement enfin il y
aura les explications de vote global
global sur le budget et le vote en
séance public donc qui devraitêre
intervenir aux alentours de 19h 19h30
nous allons suivre cela régulièrement en
rejoignant l'émissic bien sûr pour
entendre les arguments des uns et des
autres et puis nous retrouverons un
certain nombre de sénateurs de
l'ensemble des des groupes politiques
qui nous feront part de leur position
ici dans la salle des conférences du
Sénat nous allons tout de suite suivre
maintenant quelques moments du débat
dans l'hémicycle actuellement je vous le
disais sur les tous derniers articles
non rattachés à ce projet de loi de
finances 2011 puis on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes ici dans la salle des
conférences tout de suite merci monsieur
le rapporteur général l'avis de la
commission des
finances monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
les auteurs de cet amendement demandent
au gouvernement de
déposer lors de chaque débat budgétaire
un rapport rendant compte de
l'efficacité des des dispositifs de
péréquation la commission n'est pas
opposée à cette demande mais nous en
profitons monsieur le ministre pour
rappeler que nous n verrons clair dans
ce sujet si difficile et parfois
passionné de la la péréquation qu'en
ayant les informations nécessaires
et la commission des finances en ce qui
la concerne aurait besoin de connaître à
terme réguliers disons au moins une fois
par an
et
la la
somme des recettes fiscales des
collectivités
territoriales le potentiel fiscal comme
le PO
financier appréhendé au niveau national
et réparti entre les trois les trois
strates commune intercommunalité
département région nous avons donc
besoin du total des recettes
fiscales de chaque
strate du potentiel fiscal total de
chaque strate du potentiel financier
total de chaque strate commune
intercommunalité département région
pour ce qui est de l'ensemble national
mais nous avons également besoin je
terminerai par là des mêmes données par
région par région de telle sorte en
particulier que nous puissions aborder
en étant mieux documenter la question de
l'île-de-fance aujourd'hui nous
travaillons un peu à l'estime mais nous
ne disposons pas d' des informations qui
nous per permettrait de bien étayer nos
travaux donc par région il serait
également indispensable d'avoir la somme
des recettes fiscales le potentiel
fiscal le potentiel
financier pour les communes et
EPCI sans doute aussi pour les EPCI à
fiscalité professionnelle unique et pour
les départements alors je me permets de
solliciter cela pour nos futurs travaux
et dans l'immédiat en ce qui concerne
l'amendement du groupe socialiste nous
nous en remettrons à la sagesse du
Sénat merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
monsieur le Président mon chers collègue
vous demandez à ce qu'un rapport rendant
compte de l'efficacité de l'ensemble des
dispositifs de péréquation soit remis au
Parlement chaque année à l'occasion du
projet de loi de finances cette demande
légitime me semble d'ors et déjà
largement satisfaite par l'action du
gouvernement en réalité en effet est
annexé chaque année au projet de loi de
finance vous le savez un document de
transversale portant sur l'effort
financier de l'État en faveur des
collectivités territoriales dénomination
qui devrait être revu pour la prochaine
édition afin de mieux rendre compte des
relations financières entre l'État et
les collectivités territoriales au vu de
l'évolution évidemment des textes que
nous avons voté récemment ce document
traite de la péréquation d'ailleurs
l'annexe 1 est généralement consacré à
ce sujet avec une partie consacrée à
l'évaluation de l'efficacité
péréquatrice des dotations à l'avenir il
est bien entendu prévu d'enrichir ce
document d'élément d'analyse portant
spécifiquement sur les différents
mécanismes de péréquation horizontale le
document existe simplement il faudra le
compléter pour répondre aux demandes qui
viennent d'être exprimées et surtout
pour prendre en compte les évolutions
qui ont été votées entre l'année
dernière et et maintenant et en tenant
bien sûr compte de l'entrée en vigueur
de de ces mesures car évidemment il
faudra regarder ce que donne maintenant
dans la pratique l'ensemble du
dispositif tel qu'il vient d'être voté
pour que nous puissions informer euh
complètement la la Haute Assemblée le le
rapporteur général précisait que il a il
a besoin d'un certain nombre
d'évaluation tangible bien entendu il
suffira de faire en sorte que cela
puisse être défini
et le gouvernement et ses service feront
ce qui est nécessaire pour que lors du
rapport qui est remis l'ensemble des
éléments nécessaires puissent être
complet dernière précision d'ors et déjà
le texte de loi prévoit un rapport au CF
donc on a un rapport qui est soumis au
Parlement il y a par ailleurs un rapport
qui est prévu au niveau de la commission
des des finances Comité des finances
locales à partir du moment où nous avons
les deux documents qui sont préparés et
bien évidemment avec l'ensemble des
éléments particulier sur la péréquation
pense qu'il est inutile de refaire un
troisième document qui serait soumis et
qui ne ferait que reprendre en grande
partie ce que nous avons déjà proposé
par ailleurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle je propose le retrait de cette
amendement merci alors y at-il sur
l'amendement 452 les demandes
d'explication de
vote il est maintenu il est maintenu je
vais donc le mettre au voix qui est
pour qui est
contre il n pas adopté il n'est pas
adopté
alors à l'article 64 je n'ai vote sur
l'article 63 pardon vote surarticle 63
qui est
pour qui est contre l'article 63 est
adopté pas d'amendement sur l'article 64
je vous propose de le considérer comme
adopté sans opposition je vous remercie
article 64 en direct donc sur Public
Sénat la fin de la discussion du projet
de loi de finances les tous derniers
articles sont en train d'être votés
avant la nouvelle délibération qui sera
demandée par le gouvernement sur une
disposition voté par le Sénat une
disposition dépensière sur laquelle veut
revenir François Fillon le Premier
ministre il l'a indiqué ce matin le
ministre du Budget François Barin on y
voit on y on y reviendra pardon mais
j'ai à mes côté Philippe Dalier qui est
sénateur apparenté UMP de sa Saint-Denis
Philippe Dalier bonjour bonjour alors
vous vous venez de faire voter cet
après-midi assez largement par le Sénat
un amendement qui ne coûte rien à l'état
mais qui va modifier la la solidarité
financière entre les communes de la
région Île-de-France oui voilà la
péréquation financière c'est le sujet de
cet après-midi donc effectivement j'ai
proposé à mes collègues de d'ici 2015
d'augmenter de 50 % le fond de
solidarité de la région Île-deFrance
c'est-à-dire que on écrite les les les
le produit fiscal des communes les plus
riches au bénéfice de celles qui le sont
moins qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
concrètement et bien ça veut dire que
les communes qui ont un potentiel
financier faible il en a beaucoup en sc
saint Nil il y en aussi dans les hautes
scèes il y en a dans le Val de mares
mais ailleurs également en Île-de-France
mais ces communes verront effectivement
cette dotation de péréquation
progrresser de manière sensible dans les
4 années qui viennent on prend au plus
riches pour donner au plus pauvres oui
une meilleure répartition des des des
richesses fiscales donc dans cette
région Île-de-France vous savez nos
collègues de province disent souvent que
c'est la région la plus riche c'est vrai
mais au sein de cette région la plus
riche les déséquilibres sont très
importants donc il faut absolument
rectifier le tir donc on en parlait
depuis longtemps et bien là le Sénat
vient effectivement de faire un pas dans
la bonne direction avec la progression
de 50 % de ce fond de solidarité alors
vous avez obtenu le soutien de
parlementaire de l'opposition aussi sur
ce texte bah écoutez d'abord l' viis
favorable du Gouvernement ce qui est
très important et puis je crois que la
quasi-ttalité des parlementaires
présents ont adopté ce sous-amendement
je crois que quelques-uns se sont
abstenu mais très peu finalement donc
j'en suis particulièrement satisfait
c'est presque un amendement de gauche
dans l'esprit qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut rien dire ça écoutez moi je suis
un élu de Sand et je suis un élu classé
à droite et alors pour autant dans mon
département il y a des collectivité
locale de droite et de gauche qui sont
riches et de droite et de gauche qui
sont pauvres la question c'est de savoir
effectivement comment on rééquilibre les
choses et comment on fait en sorte
qu'effectivement la cohésion sociale et
urbaine de cette métropole du Grand
Paris soit assurée c'est ça l'objectif
et c'est pas un problème de droite ou de
gauche c'est un problème d'intérêt
national alors il y a un autre
amendement qui cette
fois-ci semble tout de même plus discuté
notamment qui n'a pas eu semble-t-il
l'accord du gouvernement que vous avez
dont vous êtes à l'initiative et qui
concerne une ponction qui devait être
prise dans dans la trésorerie des HLM
écoutez oui effectivement le le
gouvernement avait proposé de prélever
340 millions d'euros par an sur les
organismes HLM et nous avons réduit
cette ponction à 150 millions d'euros en
faisant en sorte également que ces 150
millions d'euros aillent entièrement au
monde HLM pour construire de nouvelles
habitations alors que précédemment dans
les 340 millions que l'État souhaitait
prélever 200 millions devaent aller au
financement de l'anrue l'Agence
nationale de rénovation ubaine nous nous
avons préféré financer l'enrue par un
autre mécanisme et faire sorte que
leshlm et bien conserve ce prélèvement
de 150 millions donc c'est vrai qu'il a
été adopté à l'unanimité du Sénat contre
l'avis du gouvernement mais là aussi il
y a rien d'anormal là-dedans le
gouvernement propose un texte le
Parlement modifie ce texte l' bande et
puis après on passe au vote donc moi il
y a rien de plus normal on a fait notre
travail de parlementaire lors du congrès
des HLM le ministre en charge du
logement le secrétaire d'État benoî appu
c'était vu un peu pris à parti par les
acteurs du monde HLM justement sur ce
projet de de taxe qui qui disaent les
responsables du mouvement HLM risquaent
de d' finalement d'empiéter sur la
capacité financière des deshlm à
construire autant de logement qu'il faut
pour répondre aux besoins des Français
est-ce que votre amendement finalement
permet de de contourner cette difficulté
ou de la surmonter bah écoutez je pense
que oui c'est vrai que les critiques qui
ont été formulées à Strasbourg contre le
ministre étaient parfois fondé et
parfois très excessive il faut aussi
rappeler qu'il y a des organismes HM qui
disposent de moyens financiers important
et qui n'ont pas forcément besoin de
construire parce qu'ils sont dans des
territoires où ce n'est pas nécessaire
donc ceuxlà que l'on les qu'on les mette
à contribution pour aider les organismes
qui ont besoin de construire là où c'est
nécessaire il n'y a rien d'anormal à ça
donc le principe d'un prélèvement est
tout à fait normal et je le soutiens
ceci étant dit 340 millions c'était
beaucoup et à mon avis trop et autre
inconvénient la totalité de la somme ne
revenait pas au monde HLM donc 150
millions destinés uniquement aux aidees
à la pierre pour aider à la construction
ça me semble effectivement un très bon
compromis ça veut dire que c'est un peu
le même esprit que le dispositif pour
pour l'Île-de-France et d'une certaine
façon les organismes HLM qui ont plus de
moyens qui vont aider ceux qui en ont le
moins à construire davantage et ben
c'est exactement ça c'est de la
péréquation financière entre organismes
HLM Vous savez on peut effectivement
toujours réclamer à l'état plus d'argent
plus d'argent et on connaît les
difficultés budgétaires de l'État mais
on peut aussi voir comment effectivement
entre organismes d'une même nature mieux
répartir les les les les produits les
les richesses et c'est ce que nous avons
fait avec le monde HLM et donc ces 150
millions le monde HLM globalement a la
capacité de les supporter et ça ira
effectivement aider ceux qui ont besoin
de construire alors un dernier mot
philippe Dallier dans quelques minutes
va débuter une discussion qui sans doute
va être assez animée puisque le
gouvernement demande une nouvelle
délibération sur un article controversé
euh qui créerait une charge financière
pour l'état de 450 million d'euros
puisque le Sénat en majorité est revenu
sur une disposition du projet de loi de
finance qui visait à supprimer des
exonérations de chargees social pour les
employeurs de personnes à domicile quel
est votre point de vue sur cette affaire
écoutez mon mon point de vue est est
partagé c'est vrai que je ne sais pas
encore très bien ce que je vais faire
d'un côté effectivement il faut bien
reconnaître que comment d'avoir permis
que les particuliers emploi des salariés
à domicile de manière complètement
transparente parce que on a quand même
fait sortir du travail au noir
énormément de personnes avec ces
dispositifs qui effectivement
accordaient des avantages fiscaux et des
réductions de charges donc on a
effectivement j'allais dire remis de
l'ordre dans tout cela aujourd'hui alors
ça coûte très cher ça effectivement c le
le le parallèle que le gouvernement
veuille effectivement diminuer la
dépense parce qu'il a besoin de réduire
le déficit budgétaire je le comprends
aussi donc effectivement là 400 millions
c'est une somme très importante je pense
donc que je je j'irai dans le sens du
gouvernement en revenant sur la la par
en deuxème délibération sur ce qui a été
adopté en première et globalement le
contexte politique de de ce vote du du
budget notamment de la part des
centristes qui ont voté justement cette
disposition contre la suppression de
l'allègement de charge comment vous le
trouvez est-ce est que d'après vous la
la majorité va montrer sa cohésion
jusque en direction des Centris écoutez
j'espère que ça sera le cas c'est vrai
que le contexte politique c'est quelque
chose d'important mais il y a aussi la
situation du pays la dette qui dépasse
les 1500 milliards d'euros le déficit
budgétaire qui sera encore l'année
prochaine aux alentours de 92 milliards
d'euros c'est beaucoup trop nous savons
d'ailleurs que dans les années à venir
il faudra faire des efforts encore plus
important donc c'est d'abord cela qu'il
faut avoir en tête comment effectivement
faire en sorte que la dette publique
n'ugmente plus et même qu'elle puisse
régresser ce qui n'a jamais été le cas
dans les 30 dernières années donc je
comprends effectivement que certains
veuillent préserver un certain nombre
d'avantage et de niche fiscale ceci
étant dit il va falloir être très
sélectif maintenir ce qui est vraiment
utile et puis effectivement revenir sur
d'autres disposition pour permettre de
réduire le déficit et donc de réduire la
dette parce que c'est l'avenir de la
France qui est en jeu et ça il ne faut
pas l'oublier merci beaucoup philippe
Dallier sénateur de sa sainten d'être
venu en direct sur le plateau de Public
Sénat rejoint l'hémicycle pour la suite
suite de la séance les derniers
amendements sur les articles non
rattachés puis on se retrouvera dans
quelques minutes ici mission
l'élargissement du périmètre des
missions de la MF alors si on s'en
refère au rapport parlementaire qui a
été fait le 28 octobre
dernier on recommande particulièrement
de faire en sorte que nous évis les les
doublons entre les autorités
indépendantes et les administration
d'une part et d'autre part j'ai bien
noté que dans l'amendement suivant le
rapporteur général du budget lui-même
euh est un peu réservé je dirais quant à
la nécessité d'abander cette autorité
administrative indépendante alors pour
ma part je souhaitais supprimer cet
article parce que on il semble que l'AMF
dispose de moyens à peu près euh
nécessaires pour remplir sa mission et
l'une des questions que je voudrais
poser au gouvernement c'est de savoir
s'il est vrai qu'à la direction de la MF
on dispose de moyens supérieurs par
exemple à l'autorité de sécurité
financière américaine qui pourtant
semble avoir un périmètre beaucoup plus
important et beaucoup plus vaste et si
il est vrai que le mode de
fonctionnement de l'autorité française
par ses habitudes de fonctionnement est
supérieure à l'autorité financière
américaine merci monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
l'amendement de philippe Dominati
s'apparente à une on aurait dit
autrefois une interpellation enfin en
tout cas c'est une question qui est
posée il exprime une préoccupation et
c'est une préoccupation qui pour une
part nous est
commune monsieur le ministre l'article
64 TER crée en effet deux nouvelles
taxes affectées à l'Autorité des marchés
financiers la première est une
contribution sur les émetteur dont la
capitalisation boursière est supérieure
à 1 milliard d'euros la seconde est une
contribution sur les grands prestataire
de service d'investissement au titre de
leurs activités de négociation pour
compte propre en clair il s'agit là des
salles de marché des grandes banques
françaises comme pour les autres taxes
affectées à la MF la loi ne fixe qu'un
plafond ou une fourchette de taux et il
revient au pouvoir réglementaire de
fixer les taux et les barêmes
applicable par cet
article il m'a semblé que le
gouvernement en
transférer 30 millions d'euros de plus à
l'Autorité des marchés financiers à
savoir 100 million d'euros pour chacune
des deux nouvelles taxes et 10 millions
d'euros par des ajustements
réglementaires portant sur d'autres
taxes
existantes notre Commission a estimé et
c'est pourquoi nous avons présenté notre
amendement qu'elle ne disposait pas des
informations permettant de justifier ce
montant de 30 millions d'euros d'autant
que la trésorerie de
l'AMF devrait toujours s'élever à la fin
de l'année entre 30 et 35 millions
d'euros c'est-à-dire l'équivalent de 5 à
6 mois de fonctionnement d'autre part
l'évaluation préalable dont nous avons
connaissance ne comporte aucun élément
sur les dépenses prévisionnel de l'AMF
d'autre part
enfin nous manquons de données sur
l'évolution prévisionnelle des taxes
déjà affectées à la MF donc Monsieur le
Ministre
ayant
manifesté la même exigence pour toute
une série d'opérateur ou d'agence de
l'État par exemple pour le Centre
national de la cinématographie il ne
serait pas normal il ne serait pas
normal pardonnez-moi que nous ne soyons
pas aussi exigeant vis-à-vis de
l'Autorité des marchés financiers d'où
notre souhait d'un abaissement du
plafond des deux nouvelles taxes afin de
limiter le transfert de ressources à 20
million d'euros mais je conclurai
monsieur le ministre en disant que sans
doute par les éléments d'information que
vous êtes susceptible de nous
apporter vous sera-t-il possible de
répondre à nos légitimes préoccupations
ce qui
assurerait une bonne fin de l'examen des
articles non rattachés de cette loi de
finances par un retrait que j'espère
possible et que j'espère partager en
fonction de ce que vous avez à nous dire
bien monsieur monsieur le rapporteur
général vous avez présenté votre
amendement
318 monsieur le rapporteur général vous
avez présenté votre amendement je
suppose que dans le même temps ça valait
avis défavorable pour l'amendement de
Monsieur dominetti ça valait demande
conditionnelle DEET très bien monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs les les
sénateur on a bien compris que nous
avons deux amendements un qui concerne
la
suppression de ces deux nouvelles taxes
permettant d'avoir des ressources
nouvelles pour la MF et de l'autre la
limitation à 25 millions d'euros de la
hausse des ressources de
l'AMF dire que nous partageons tout à
fait le le souci RPP par le rapporteur
général de limiter au strict minimum les
les moyens de
l'autorité de l'AMF le Gouvernement
partage tout à fait l'intention de la
représentation nationale de veiller à un
usage mesuré et efficace des ressources
public par les autorités administratives
indépendantes manifesté notamment dans
le rapport parlementaire rendu public le
28 octobre dernier notamment vudrait
quand même redire que nous avons décidé
au Parlement de confier à laamf en plus
des responsabilités qu'il avait qu'elle
avait trois points premièrement la NF
pourra désormais sanctionner les abus de
marché sur les marchés dérivés CDC et
matières premières notamment
deuxièmement la loi a changé charger la
MF de contrôler surveiller les ventes à
découvert et troisièmement la MF se
devra de contrôler surveiller
sanctionner les marchés de
carbone c'est euh
responsabilité supplémentaire c'est
notamment la commission des finances de
la haute assemblée qui a souhaité les
confier à la MF nous sommes maintenant
dans la situation de devoir au niveau de
la MF faire face à un nouveau périmètre
de travaux et c'est pour permettre à ce
nouveau périmètre d'être opérationnel et
de répondre à ce besoin d'investigation
que ces moyens supplémentaires sont
prévus faudrais simplement dire que le
plan stratégique de l'AMF prévoit la
création de 65 nouveaux emplois entre
2010 et 2012 ce qui fera passer les
effectifs totaux de l'autorité de 404
emplois en 2010 à 469 en 2012 fin 2010
les effectifs totaux seront de 420
postes c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous comprenez bien que tout en ayant la
volonté de réduire les dépenses il est
difficile de ne pas permettre une
augmentation des moyens pour autant ces
moyens nouveaux n'exclut pas la
recherche d'économie les programmes
d'économie décidés par la MF ont permis
de réduire de 1,1 million d'euros les
dépenses générales en 2009 et de 3,2 2,3
million d'euros en 2010 en outre la
hausse des effectifs de la MF se fera
parc immobilier
constant en réponse à philippe Dominati
je voudrais lui indiquer qu'un périmètre
constant dans l'intervention des agences
de régulation il n'y a pas de problème
en France nous sommes sous le les
montants qui sont utilisés aux
États-Unis je le rassure périmètre
constant sachant que bien entendu il
peut y avoir des périmètres
d'intervention différents et nous voyons
que là en l'occurrence nous sommes en
train de l'augmenter par contre au
niveau de la réponse à apportter à notre
rapporteur général je voudrais
l'informer que s'agissant des moyens je
suis prêt à prendre l'engagement devant
la Haute Assemblée de limiter à 25
millions d' en 2011 la hausse des
ressources de la MF décidée par les
pouvoirs publics donc de répondre très
concrètement à l'amendement qu'il avait
proposé pour me remettre donc à traduire
dans le concret les propositions qu'il
formulait par amendement et c'est raison
pour laquelle je vous demanderai
monsieur rapporteur général de bien
vouloir retirer cet amendement puisque
dans la pratique nous répondrons à vos
exigences alors l'amendement 318 est
retiré l'amendement 40 rectifié monsieur
dominetti si je peux interrompre il est
re il est retiré également je vous
remerci alors je vais je vais mettre au
voie l'amend l'article 64 TER y a-t-il
sur cet article d'exlication de vote je
n'en vois pas qui est
pour qui est
contre il est adopté nous en avons mes
chers
collèguesur attend monsieur bar alors
mais on en a quand même terminé avec
l'examen des articles de la seconde
partie
et la parole sera donnée
au ministre du Budget dès qu'il sera
parmi
nous il est en
dinde
30 secondes la
parole permettez-moi simpl
i voilà nous sommes maintenant à
quelques instants de la deuxème
délibération d'une des dispositions qui
a été votée par le Sénat et qui est
contestée par le gouvernement qui
concerne les les allègements de charges
accordés aux personnes qui emploient des
salariés à domicile des allègements de
charges sur lequel veut revenir le
gouvernement de manière partielle mais
qui notamment pour les fédérations sur
les employeurs à domicile sur les
services à la personne risque de
pénaliser le développement de ce secteur
qui a connu une forte création d'emplois
ces dernières années pour le
gouvernement il s'agit tout simplement
de ne pas accroître le déficit
budgétaire car l'amendement qui a été
voté par le Sénat représente présente
450 millions de plus de dépenses et donc
françois Barouin le ministre du Budget
va s'exprimer dans un petit instant
devant les sénateurs pour expliquer la
raison pour laquelle il demande au
parlementaires de revenir sur cette
disposition on écoute le ministre du
Budget le 43 alé 4 du Règlement du Sénat
le gouvernement vous le savez demande
une seconde délibération sur l'article
48 les crédits du budget général et
l'État B l'article 90 et pour
coordination avec les votes intervenus
au cours de la seconde partie sur
l'article 40 7 relatif à l'équilibre du
budget je vais me livrer si vous me le
permettez rapidement à une présentation
groupée des 24 amendements déposés par
le gouvernement dont 22 visistent en
réalité à répondre aux demandes
formulées par votre commission des
finances et dont le dernier n'est qu'un
amendement de coordination j'y
reviendrai furtivement par cette seconde
délibération le gouvernement souhaite en
effet revenir sur un seul vote de votre
assemblée celui ayant conduit à
supprimer l'article 90 du projet de loi
de finances relatif au service à la
personne le Sénat en effet rejeter
l'économie la plus importante du projet
de loi de finance à savoir la
suppression des exonérations de charges
concernant les services à la personne
c'est-à-dire l'abortement des 15 points
pour les particuliers employeurs
exonération spécifique qui me soit
permis devant la Haute Assemblée de
rappeler que c'est une économie à
hauteur de 460 millions pour l'année
2011 700 millions pour l'année 2012 je
pourrais rappeler devant la Haute
Assemblée comme je l'ai fait il y a
quelques
instants sollicité ainsi par le groupe
centriste à l'Assemblée nationale que je
rends hommage à la haute assemblée qui a
voté la loi de programmation des
finances publiques et qui nous fixe un
cadre ce cadre général c'est un plan
global d'économie à hauteur de 100
milliards sur les 3 années qui viennent
ce sont des objectifs intangibles de
réduction de déficit pour l'année
prochaine comme vous le savez à 6 % pour
l'année suivante à 4,6 %, pour l'année
2013 nous fixons ainsi un rendez-vous de
retrouver le niveau déficit que nous
avions avant la crise et même en 2014 un
niveau de déficit par rapport à à notre
richesse nationale à hauteur de 2 %. je
pourrais rappeler en élément comparatif
me semble-t-il pertinent que le plan
allemand est un plan de 80 milliards sur
4 ans le plan français est un plan de
100 milliards sur 3 ans c'est dire la
puissance de l'effort proposé par le
gouvernement soutenu par sa majorité je
le remercie pour permettre de d'éloigner
progressivement cette épée de damoclesè
qui pèse sur la tête de chaque français
et qui porte tout simplement le nom de
la dette trop élevée pour un pays comme
le nôtre ce qui est le cas de tous les
autres pays la zone euro nous le voyons
bien avec la crise irlandaise actuelle
et c'est que les cas dans la
détermination d'une nouvelle inflexion
en matière de finances publ par rapport
aux objectifs et aux engagements pris
par la France nous devons donc y
parvenir pour cela il y a une addition
de mesures et cette addition de mesur
suppose naturellement de faire des choix
s'agissant de cette question des aides à
la personne vous le savez c'est un
dispositif qui repose sur deux éléments
de niche une niche fiscale et une niche
sociale un avantage fisc et un avantage
social le gouvernement respecte en cela
là aussi les engagements qu'il a pris de
ne pas toucher aux avantages fiscaux un
autre choix aurait pu se présenter tout
aussi difficile tout aussi animé dans
les débats que nous avons eu les uns
avec les autres qui aurait été par
exemple de placer l'avantage fiscal sous
la toise du rabot il y aurait eu me
semble-t-il là encore matière à
discussion et de matière beaucoup plus
souligné car en effet s été une remise
en cause un dispositif qui a prouvé son
efficacité s'agissant de la remise en
cause de l'avantage des 15 points
d'exénération de cotisation sociale nous
sommes là dans une logique de remise en
cause d'un dispositif d'histoire récente
je rappelle que en 4 années ça la mise
en place de cette abortement de 15
points cette niche sociale complétant la
niche fiscale était venu pour redonner
un peu d'élan à un dispositif qui en
avait besoin en 4 années il y a eu une
augmentation de 50 % de l'évolution du
du coup représentant naturellement un
effort trop douloureux compte tenu de la
situation de nos finances publiques je
voudrais dire singulièrement à ceux qui
s'interrogent légitimement sur la
question des publics fragiles et qui
disposent de cet
avantage je veux en particulier me
tourner vers le président Abou et à
travers lui naturellement toutes celles
et tous ceux qui au sein de la Haute
Assemblée sont venus animer le débat
autour de cette problématique des aides
à la personne qu'ils peuvent être
pleinement rassuré j'ai donné tous les
éléments
conformés évidemment à la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale sur
la problématique de cette suppression
d'abattement qui n'impacte en rien les
publbiqus fragiles cette suppression ne
concerne pas les personnes de plus de 60
ans sujet handicap ne concerne pas les
attributaires de la pas ne concerne pas
les personnes de plus de 70 ans ne
concerne pas les parents d'enfants
handicapés ne concernent pas les
handicapés
eux-mêmes cette ce système d'exonération
sociale représente
100illard soit trois fois plus que la
mesure d'économie que le gouvernement
vous propose c'est dire qu'en ayant
répondu à l'interrogation légitime
concernant les publics fragiles le
gouvernement me semble-t-il lève la
question prioritaire des interrogations
d'un certain nombre de membres de la
haute assemblée c'est dire qu'en ayant
mis en perspective cette mesure
d'économie qui conforte par ailleurs
l'avantage fiscal dont bénéficient les
attributaires de cette aide à la
personne c'est dire qu'ayant remis en
perspective cette mesure d'économie dans
le cadre général de l'économie
budgétaire que nous proposons il me
semble que le gouvernement apporte tous
les éléments de réponse et d'apaisement
susceptible de nourrir et de justifier
cette deuxème délibération concernant
l'ensemble des ménages je je je rappelle
que les avantages fiscaux maintenus
représentent 4 milliards et 4 milliards
c'est important et je rappelle enfin que
l'ensemble des aides au secteur des
services à la personne représente 6
milillard 8 ce coût ayant augmenté là
encore de 50 % entre 2006 et 2010 je n'y
reviendrai pas je crois que vous avez
tous les éléments pour nourrir votre
réflexion sur la deuxiè délibération
proposée par le gouvernement au-delà de
ce sujet essentiel la Haute Assemblée a
adopté plusieurs amendements conduisant
Infiné à accroître les dépenses
budgétaires ou fiscales qui ne sont pas
compatibles avec nos objectifs de
finances publiques mais le gouvernement
fait confiance naturellement à la
représentation nationale pour trouver
les voies et moyens d'atteindre
l'objectif compatible avec le vote
positif autour de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques et
rendant coordonné le vote de la loi de
finances pour l'année prochaine qui est
un élément une étape le premier étage de
la fusée qui nous amènera à l'équilibre
budgétaire d'ici 2016 ou 2017 c'est la
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement n'a
pas placé dans cette seconde
délibération des sujets qui concernent
et qui ont nourr de manière assez
vigoureuse d'ailleurs nos débats à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat je pense à la
question concernant la pèéquation HLM et
le financement du Grand Paris qui
revient à faire financer majoritairement
la bosse de dépenses de l'anrue par la
région île-de- France et parce qu'il
prive aussi d'une part prépondérante de
ces recettes la Société du Grand Paris
je pense également à une série
d'amendements de crédit concernant les
crédits du FISAC vous avez en face de
vous également un élu local qui sait la
puissance de la portée de cet outil mais
qui sait aussi l'esprit de
responsabilité qui nous anime tous
Lorsque nous devons atteindre l'objectif
que nous nous fixons je pense en matière
fiscale à l'amendement qui prévoit le
maintien en 2012-2013 de la
défiscalisation en faveur des
biocarburants c'est une charge
supplémentaire de 200 millions j'en
appelle naturellement sur l'ensemble de
ces sujets à la sagesse et à l'esprit de
responsabilité de la commission mixte
paritaire mais je ne vous propose pas
dans cette seconde délibération ayant
écouté et entendu bon nombre de messages
au sein de l'UMP comme au sein du groupe
centriste porté en cela par l'excellent
rapporteur général et l'excellent
président de la commission des finances
auquel je tiens à rendre hommage le soin
de définir les modalités avec
l'Assemblée nationale pour trouver des
points d'accord et d'équilibre du budget
je voudrais au-delà de ces sujets
essentiels pour l'équilibre du budget
2011 vous proposez d'adopter aussi dans
le cadre de cette seconde délibération
un amendement technique visant à
traduire dans l'article d'équilibre les
votes intervenus lors de l'examen de la
seconde partie du projet de loi de
financeces et puis une série
d'amendements visant à répondre
favorablement aux propositions de votre
commission des finances je le dis avec
la modestie et la pudeur ise pour cette
clause de style maisura chacun aura bien
compris ici ce que cela recouvre en
abondant à hauteur de 58 millions
d'euros les crédits d'un certain nombre
de missions qui vous concernent tous
dans les départements dont vous avez
l'honneur de représenter les couleurs
ici dans cette haute assemblée pour
conclure cette seconde délibération je
tiens à saluer la qualité des travaux
menés au sein du Sénat l'arbre ne doit
pas cacher la forêt je ne souhaite pas
qu'on retienne de ces semaines très
longues et très importantes de travail
commun que cette seconde délibération
absolument nécessaire pour nous rappeler
au respect de la matrice et des
principes du budget 2011 dans lequel la
majorité de la Haute Assemblée je le
sais se reconnais je veux aussi qu'on
rentienne la somme des travaux
constructifs d'enregissement apporté au
projet de budget dont témoigne quelques
chiffres 200 amendements ont été
acceptés par le gouvernement sur la
totalité des 900 qui ont été proposés
tous ceux qui ont une mémoire je croise
le regard d'un certain nombre d'anciens
titulaires de ce portefeuille ou qui ont
exercé des responsabilités plus élevé à
ber savent que un gouvernement qui dans
un contexte d'exigence budgétaire
continue d'accepter à hauteur de 200
amendements c'est le fruit me
semble-t-il d'un échange fructueux
positif et vertueux et tout simplement
bien naturel entre l'exécutif que je
représente devant vous et le législatif
que vous incarnez et que vous portez
compte tenu du nombre de ces amendements
et conformément à l'article 44 alinéa 3
de la Constitution et l'article 42
alinéa 7 du Règlement du Sénat le
gouvernement demande qu'il soit procédé
à un seul vote sur les articles
amendements faisant l'objet de cette
seconde délibération je vous remercie
pour votre
attention merci Monsieur le
Ministre alors quel est l'avis de la
commission sur la demande de seconde
délibération bien monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la
Commission a besoin d'exam le contenu de
cette seconde délibération pour exprimer
un avis et donc je demande monsieur le
Président que l'on suspende la séance
afin que la Commission puisse se réunir
je pense que 15 minutes sont nécessaires
aux membres de la commission des
finances que j'invite à se retrouver
salle des
commissions mes chers collèges monsieur
le Président j'ai une légère digence
d'interprétation du règlement avec vous
puisque le renvoi en commission pour une
seconde délibération doit être décidé
par le Sénat et donc qu'il faut que sur
cette le principe de la seconde
libération j'ai compris puisque vous
demandiez la réunion de la commission
que vous y étiez favorable je me dois
demander maintenant à l'Assemblée s'il y
a un orateur
contre cette ce principe de seconde
délibération si je vois pas je vais
consulter le Sénat monsieur Abou contre
alors je vous donne pas la parole
monsieur le Président suspension de
séance alors je vais consulter le Sénat
sur la seconde sur la demande de seconde
délibération qui est
pourou qui est
contre
la demande le renvoi à la commission est
décidée alors conformément à l'article
43 al 5 lorsqu'il y a seconde
délibération les textes adoptés lors de
la première ser envoyé à la commission
qui doit présenter un nouveau rapport la
Commission comme nous l'a évoqué le
président Jean va se réunir pour
présenter son
rapport il a demandé une suspension 15
minutes monsieur le Président c'est que
vousz a demandé monsieur Abou monsieur
le Président Abou comment on peut
joindre l'utile l'agréable la suspension
de séance 15 minutes
aussi alors alors les deux sont
conjoints et nous repronons dans 15
minutes voilà vous venez de l'entendre
cette deuxième délibération sur un
article clé du projet de loi de finances
fait donc maintenant l'objet d'une
suspension de séance d'une quinzaine de
minutes le temps de permettre à la
commission des finances d'examiner la
proposition qui est faite par le
gouvernement de revenir à son texte
initial je vous rappelle que l'enjeu
c'est la suppression voulue par le
gouvernement d'un abattement de
cotisation sociale pour les personnes
qui emploient des salariés à domicile il
s'agit d'un enjeu financier pour l'année
prochaine de 450 millions d'euros le
Sénat s'est opposé à cette suppression
mais comme l'a souligné françois Barouin
le ministre du Budget euh si la
disposition du Sénat devait être
maintenue bien évidemment ce serait une
charge supplémentaire pour le budget de
l'État ce que refuse le gouvernement
dans cette période de 10ette budgétaire
vous l'avez entendu d'ailleurs sur un
certain nombre d'autres points le
gouvernement laisse le soin à la
commission mixte paritaire qui se
réunira la semaine prochaine entre
députés et sénateurs de trouver un
accord pour ne pas alourdir la charge
budgétaire en revanche là il s'agit d'un
élément clé puisque selon françois
Barouin euh il s'agit de l'économie la
plus importante contenue dans ce budget
2011 450 millions d'euros mais sur un
sujet sensible celui de l'emploi à
domicile parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un des gisements qui a permis beaucoup
de création d'emploi ces dernières
années alors néanmoins l'argument
utilisé par le gouvernement est que
d'une part et bien il subsiste la
réduction fiscale à laquelle il n'a pas
été touché alors qu'àun moment il avait
été question de coup de rabau qui fait
que lorsque vous payez un salarié à
domicile vous pouvez déduire 50 %
jusqu'à un certain plafond des sommes
dépensées salaire plus charge de votre
feuille d'impôt et puis il y a une
deuxième sécurité en quelque sorte ce
qui justifie aujourd'hui la demande de
délibération du gouvernement qui est que
les publics fragiles et c'est une
question sur lequelle le Sénat avit
insisté notamment à travers sa
commission des affaires sociales euh
personnes âgées dépendantes ou personnes
handicapées ou parents de personnes
handicapées employant des salariés à
domicile les publics fragiles vont
continuer de bénéficier de cette
exonération voilà donc le ministre du
Budget françois Barouin a défendu la
position du gouvernement les commissions
se réunissent pour un quart d'heure et
puis la séance va reprendre ici au Sénat
il y aura les l'expression des
différents groupes bien entendu le
gouvernement va obtenir gain de cause de
la majorité à moins vraiment d'une euh
coalition tout de même très forte de
l'ensemble des centristes avec
l'opposition on peut penser que quelques
voix centristes qui ont permis
l'adoption de l'amendement contesté
aujourd'hui vont peut-être rejoindre
l'avis du gouvernement on va essayer
d'en savoir plus dans les minutes qui
suivent après quoi il y aura les
explications de vote sur l'ensemble de
ce budget 2011 de la part de chacun des
groupes le vote devrait intervenir vers
19h nous serons toujours en direct sur
Public Sénat peut-être pendant l'édition
que présentera Michel grossior et puis
une fois le texte adopté et bien c'est
donc je vous le disais une commission
mixte paritaire qui se réunira lundi
prochain pour harmoniser la version du
budget voté par l'Assemblée nationale
avec celle qui a été votée par le Sénat
avant que l'Assemblée et le Sénat ne se
prononce en milieu de semaine pour une
lecture définitive et une adoption
définitive de ce projet de loi de
finances qui réduit le déficit
budgétaire assez fortement l'année
prochaine même si il va rester important
qui réduit donc ce déficit budgétaire
qui va passer de quelques 150 milliards
d'euros autour tout de même encore de 90
milliards d'euros il y a encore des
efforts à faire puisque pour revenir au
3 % c'est-à-dire avant la crise 50
milliards d'euros il faudra encore 2
années voilà c'est dire que la route
budgétaire de la France est
particulièrement sinueuse et compliquée
et que les budgets
de 2012 avant l'élection présidentielle
seront au moins aussi discutés disputés
que ne l' ce projet de loi de finances
pour cette année alors ça c'est le
premier débat et puis il y a un autre
débat qui attend aussi le gouvernement
qu' a lui-même ouvert c'est celui de la
réforme fiscal et là depuis quelques
jours on s'aperçoit qu'il y a des voix
dissonnantes au sein de la majorité vous
savez qu'il est question de supprimer à
la fois l'impôt sur la fortune et le
bouclier fiscal reste que là aussi il y
a une équation financière difficile car
si on supprime les deux il y aura un
manque à gagner pour l'état de plus de 3
milliards d'euros et là il y a au sein
du gouvernement au sein de la majorité
un certain nombre de visions différentes
de ce que pourrait être la réforme
fiscale nous avons avec nous le sénateur
centriste Hervé Moret qui nous a rejoint
alors Monsieur Moret le la commission
des finances se réunit actuellement sur
cette seconde délibération on sait que
les voix centristes ont pesé en faveur
de l'adoption de cette disposition qui
revenait donc sur la suppression
d'exonération de charges sociales pour
les emplois à domicile est-ce que vous
avez été sensible aux arguments employés
il y a quelques minutes par le ministre
du Budget françois Barouin écoutez pas
vraiment on reste sur une position où
les centristes aussi bien à l'Assemblée
nationale d'Ur qu'au Sénat considère que
c'est une disposition qui a des effets
tout à fait utiles en terme d'emploi en
terme d'aide aux personnes en difficulté
donc on reste très attaché à ce à ce
dispositif que nous avons rétabli ici
c'est-à-dire que il y a une une
possibilité
que le gouvernement ne trouve pas de
majorité pour revenir sur le vote qui
est intervenu écoutez on va avoir quel
est l'avis de la commission des finances
notre groupe doit se réunir aussi pour
essayer de prendre une position commune
sur ce sujet rien n'est rien n'est
certain alors qu'il est au-delà il y a
aussi une question de principe c'est le
fait que le gouvernement nous demande
comme il l'avait fait à l'Assemblée
nationale alors ici il le fait de
manière moins massive de revenir sur des
votes que que nous avons émis donc si
vous voulez il y a un vote à 450
millions d'euros oui bien sûr mais vous
savez euh c'est facile de montrer du
doigt certaines dépenses et puis de
fermer les yeux sur d'autres on pourrait
tout à fait trouver des économies de
cette ampleur ailleurs le gouvernement
est un peu sélectif dans sa manière de
montrer du doigt certains dispositifs
donc là on est on est attaché à cette
mesure et on va voir ce qu'on décide en
réunion de groupe mais je vous dis
au-delà il y a aussi une question de
principe et et moi personnellement je
suis très choqué que le gouvernement
alors qu'en plus de tout il y aura
ensuite mix paritaire qui peut permettre
de revoir le dispositif après des heures
et des heures de débats ici il y a des
parlementaires qui ont passé des jours
et des nuits arrivent en claquant des
doigts et en disant bah tiens ça je vous
demande de revenir dessus donc il y a la
question de la forme et il y a la
question du fond on va essayer d'y
répondre et sur les emplois à
domicile on sait qu'il y a quand même
l'essentiel c'est la mesure de réduction
fiscale à laquelle le gouvernement n'a
pas touché c'est-à-dire le fait qu'on
réduise de ses impôts 50 % de la charge
salaire plus charge sociale d'un emploi
domissile est-ce que d'une certaine
façon il n'y a pas malgré tout un un
équilibre pour si on veut favoriser ce
secteur qui qui est trouvé et qui est
préservé par le gouvernement écoutez moi
j'ai le sentiment que l'équilibre du
dispositif tel qu'il existe à à ce jour
est satisfaisant alors on peut discuter
à l'infini de savoir si si on peut le
raboter ou pas moi je pense qu'il est
satisfaisant je pense qu'il permet euh à
des gens d'avoir des aides à domicile
alors qu'il ne le pourrai pas autrement
qu'il permet de de créer l'emploi qu'il
évite le le travail au noir euh voilà
donc je pense que c'est un bon
dispositif et que 150 millions vous
savez ça on aurait pu les les les
trouver sur sur d'autres dispositifs on
a eu des longs débats sur le crédit impô
recherche qui coûte plusieurs milliards
on a eu de de longs débats sur la TVA
sur la restauration qui coûte plusieurs
milliards il y a des dispositifs qui se
chiffrent en milliards donc voilà c'est
pourquoi pointer du doigt ce dispositif
qui est qui est utile qui est qui est
juste socialement et qui est efficace
voilà alors réponse sur le vote des
centristes dans quelques minutes mais
vous avez l'air de de vouloir tenir bon
on va aller en réunion de groupe on
verra après merci beaucoup merci à vous
merci
nous accueillons monsieur Fortassin
c'est bien ça c'est ça c'est sénateur
radical du groupe radical des haut
Pyréné des haute pyrénée merci de de
nous avoir rejoint votre position sur ce
débat car donc réouvert le gouvernement
est-ce que vous êtes convaincu par les
arguments du ministre du Budget qui
estime que malgré tout l'essentiel reste
préservé en ce qui concerne les
avantages donnés aux personnes qui
emploient des salariés à domicile non je
ne suis pas fondamentalement d'accord je
dirais que le budget qui nous est
proposé et les mesures qui nous sont
proposées sont en définitive des mesures
de techniciens et non pas des mesures
politiques et en plus il y a un problème
fondamental en définitive on va revenir
sur des amendements qui avait été décidé
par le Sénat ce qui est en définitive
contraire à l'état d'esprit que l'on
peut avoir et à la conception que l'on a
de du rôle du Parlement juste sur ce
point et c'est sans doute pas la
première fois dans dans l'histoire
budgétaire quelle que soit la majorité
que le gouvernement demande une deuxième
délibération non c'est techniquement
c'est tout à fait faisable je trouve
simplement que politiquement c'est
regrettable compte tenu de la volonté
qui s'était manifestée par un vote
positif de l'Assemblée sur cette mesure
là alors et en même temps chacun sait
bien et c'est ce qu'a dit le ministre du
Budget que des économies budgétaires
sont sont nécessaires lui il dit que
c'est c'est la mesure qui génère le plus
d'économie dans ce budget 2011 est-ce
que dans le contexte actuelle on voit la
crise financière qui touche beaucoup de
pays il faut pas accepter ce type de de
sacrifice c'est une façon de voir les
choses par contre on n peut-être pas
fait si je peux dire tout tous les
efforts nécessaires pour accentuer les
recette et en particulier je prendrai
une seule mesure lorsque j'ai
personnellement proposé au cours des
débats précédents que les revenus du
capital et du patrimoine soit frappé au
même titre que les revenus du travail C
cette proposition a été balayée dans
revers de main et j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire qu'en définitive les ministres les
différents ministres se comportai comme
des tradeers et des banquiers et non
comme des élus politiques sauf qu'il va
y avoir une réforme fiscale qui va
permettre de remettre ça à plat l'année
prochaine peut-être mais pour l'instant
nous ne sommes pas là nous sommes au au
budget 2011 que nous devons voter enfin
pour ma part je ne ventterai pas merci
beaucoup François Fortassin sénateur
radical des Hautes Pyrénées nous
accueillons maintenant Didier Guillaume
sénateur socialiste et président du
conseil général de la drô Didier
Guillaume bonjour le gouvernement a donc
demandé une seconde délibération la
commission des finances le groupe
centriste qui a permis l'adoption de cet
amendement avec en joignant ses voix à
celle de l'opposition se réunit
également en ce moment est-ce qu'il y a
pas malgré tout dans l'argumentation
utilisée par françois Barouin des
élément convainquants dans la mesure où
l'essentiel est préservé sur les
réductions d'impôts concernant les
emplois à domicile et dans dans la
mesure où il faut malgré tout réaliser
un certain nombre d'efforts budgétaires
que font aussi nos voisins européens je
crois que faire des efforts budgétaires
tout le monde est d'accord tous les
groupes sont d'accord simplement nous ce
que nous disons c'est que il faut pas
chercher les petites niche il faut
chercher les grosses et aujourd'hui il y
a possibilité de faire ces économies sur
des grosses niches fiscales des grosses
économies et en ce qui concerne ce point
précis faut pas que ce soit toujours les
mêmes qui qui qui payent alors j'ai
entendu les arguments de du ministre
évidemment est-ce qu'ils sont
convaincants ils peuvent se comprendre
mais moi il ne m'ont pas convaincu ils
n'ont pas convaincu notre notre groupe
et je pense que le Sénat sonore de
prendre des positions de les garder non
pas pour être dogmatique mais de dire à
un moment ou un autre ce ne sont pas
toujours les mêmes qui doivent trinquer
ce sont pas toujours les classes
moyennes qui doivent qui doivent
trinquer et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne sais pas comment les
choses vont se vont se passer mais enfin
le gouvernement veut passer en force
dans son budget sans tenir compte de la
commission des finances sans tenir
compte de la vie du Sénat ben
aujourd'hui le Sénat dans une
conjoncture un peu spécifique avec euh
euh une majorité qui s'est fait à la
fois avec des centristes des des des des
sénateurs de gauche montre que le Sénat
ne veut pas se faire balloter tout le
temps sans cesse donc vous pensez que
une majorité au Sénat peut encore se
dégager pour maintenir la version
initiale de ce qui a été voté par les
les sénateurs ben écoutez moi je
l'espère si ce n'est pas le cas ça
voudra dire qu'il y aura eu des
pressions terribles on a connu par le
passé la loi sur la réforme des
collectivités territoriales est passé de
quelques voix quatre voix parce qu'il y
a eu des pressions terribles de l'Élysée
du gouvernement de tout le monde on va
bien voir ce qui va se passer ici je
pense qu'il est encore possible que qu'
a une majorité alors après on dit mais
les Centris c'est toujours comme cela
ils font beaucoup de bruit ils
interviennent en séance puis après une
Infiné ben ils suivent ce que leur dit
le gouvernement on va voir moi je ne
fais aucun procès d'intention je pense
qu'il y a des débats de fond qui
méritent d'être menés jusqu'au bout eu
juste un dernier mots je m'adresse au
président du conseil général de laadrome
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire ce
weekend a indiqué que euh la centrale de
Tricastin qui se trouve implantée dans
votre département pourrait poursuivre
son activité au-delà de ce qui était
initialement prévu durée de vie au
départ 30 ans on devrait passer à 40 ans
est-ce que c'est une bonne décision
selon vous c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour l'industrie nucléaire évidemment
pour mon département mais le département
de la Drome ne compte pas dans dans ce
cas-là c'est une très bonne nouvelle
parce qu'il y a besoin de faire
plusieurs démonstrations la première
c'est que l'énergie nucléaire est
aujourd'hui une énergie indispensable à
notre auto omie française et voire à
l'exportation deuxièmement que cette
énergie nucléaire aujourd'hui ne produit
pas de gaz à effet de serre
troisièmement c'est que la sécurité que
la recherche a suffisamment fait de
d'effort suffisamment fait d'avancer
afin de pouvoir prolonger la durée de
vie des centrales c'est une très bonne
nouvelle je crois que nous avons la
chance d'avoir dans ce pays un gendarme
du nucléaire le meilleur du monde ou un
des tout meilleur du monde il faut lui
faire confiance moi quand le quand la
l'autorité de sreté nucléaire met des
avis je ne suis jamais je me dis jamais
mais ils exagèrent c'est la sécurité qui
prime avant tout et la transparence et
aujourd'hui que l'ASN fasse la
démonstration qu'il y a possibilité
d'augmenter d'une dizaine d'années
peut-être plus la durée de vie des
centrales en France ça nous laisse
augurer un meilleur avenir pour la
filière énergétique française maintenant
il faudra aussi que le gouvernement
prenne des décisions mettre en place une
vraie stratégie que l'équipe de France
du nucléaire l'équipe de France enfin
soit une vraie équipe de France avec un
pack conquurrent mais ça c'est un autre
débat VO a un discours très pro
nucléaire on comprend parce que
effectivement c'est un élément de la vie
de votre département en même temps il y
a aussi les objections de ceux qui
disent par oui pas de gaz à effet de
serre mais beaucoup d'incertitude sur la
gestion des déchets beaucoup
d'interrogations malgré tout sur la
sécurité de central dont la durée de vie
va être prolongée absolument c'est pour
ça que moi dans le dans le cadre de
l'énergie c'est pas parce que la
centrale nucléaire est sur mon
département c'est bien sûr que c'est pas
anodin d'avoir la plus grande centrale
nucléaire d'Europe chez soi mais en même
temps je réfléchis à notre indépendance
énergétique je réfléchis à à l'avenir de
notre mix énergétique qui est
indispensable et aujourd'hui tous les
Français comprennent bien que c'est pas
d'être prcléaire c'est une indépendance
mix énergétique une autonomie parfaite
pouvoir aller à l'exportation gagner des
gagner des des marchés et le fait que la
recherche fasse du de de Phe des
évolutions va bien moi je prône
l'exigence la transparence et la
sécurité si ce striptic est réalisé je
pense que l'énergie nucléaire peut
avancer alors il y a le problème des
déchets et bien il faut faire encore des
des efforts pour leur pour leur
traitement l'Andra avance beaucoup il
faudra sûrement passer demain à une
autre génération à voir mais aujourd'hui
l'énergie nucléaire est acceptée par la
population un effort a été fait dans les
années 70 ben il faut maintenant le
prolonger aller plus loin il en va de
notre indépendance mais en même temps il
faut prener la transparence est
indispensable merci beaucoup Didier
Guillaume sénateur socialiste de la
Drome la séance devrait reprendre dans
dans quelques minutes et d'ici là nous
accueillons le sénateur UMP paul Blanc
qui va nous rejoindre ici signateur P
des Pyrénées Orientales monsieur blanc
bonjour oui bonjour alors Monsieur blanc
ici au Sénat vous êtes beaucoup mobilisé
depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant on vous don d'ailleurs
notamment le travail de la dernière loi
sur le sujet sur la question des
personnes handicapées alors elles sont
au premier chef concernés par les
dispositions concernant l'emploi ou
l'aide à domicile est-ce que les
assurances qui ont été données par
françois Barouin le ministre du Budget
qui veut donc reprendre ce qui a été
voté par le Sénat vous paraisse
suffisant
écoutez je crois que j'ai été rapporteur
de budget solidarité qui bien entendu
englobe en particulier les personnes
handicapées et je crois que j'ai
pratiquement obtenu satisfacation
pratiquement surtout donc je suis
relativement satisfait en étant quand
même conscient que le budget 2011 est un
budget difficile et que tout le monde va
être obligé euh à faire quelques
sacrifices parce que la situation de
notre pays est une situation extrêmement
difficile et d'ailleurs parallèlement à
ce budget de la nation il y a également
le budget de la Sécurité sociale qui il
faut le rappeler représente une fois et
demi le budget de la Nation et tout est
un petit peu lié puisque par exemple
dans le budget de la Sécurité sociale
vous avez la prise en compte le
financement des maisons d'accueil
spécialisé des masses qui sont pris en
charge par la sécurité sociale et de ce
côté-là nous avons des assurances de
continuer à pouvoir ouvrir des places
pour accueillir les personnes
handicapées lourdement handicapées qui
sont celles qui sont habituellement
hébergées dans les masses donc je crois
que de ce côté-là on est relativement
satisfait alors vous confirmez qu'on
peut aujourd'hui assurer les personnes
handicapés ou leurs parents que ceux qui
emploient des personnes à domicile pour
l'aide au au quotidien euh et bien vont
garder le même régime de réduction
sociale et fiscale pour ses emplois à
domicile écoutez à l'heure où je vous
parle euh je viens d'entendre les propos
du ministre j'ai une certitude c'est que
les améliorations fiscales vont être
approuvver continuer à pouvoir
s'appliquer en ce qui concerne les
exonérations de charge social il y a
semble-t-il encore des dispositions qui
sont encore en cours d'étude par la
commission des finances je peux pas vous
le dire en ce moment même je pourrais
vous en dire peut-être plus dans tris
qu4 d'heure ou dans une heure mais
j'espère qu'on arrivera à trouver un
terrain d'entente en particulier en ce
qui concerne les associations qui
s'occupent des problèmes d'emploi à
domicde on est lancé sur un grand débat
qui doit aboutir théoriquement en 2011
qui est celui de la la dépendance des
personnes âgées quand on voit la
difficulté qu'on a à garder tel avantage
fiscal qui sont des avantages malgré
tout à but social soit pour de l'emploi
soit pour aider des personnes qui sont
en difficulté est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on va pouvoir résoudre ce Castet
financier je pense qu'on ne va pas le
résoudre dans l'état actuel et que la
solidarité nationale ne pourra pas
s'occuper de tout d'ailleurs vous savez
j'avais déposé une proposition de loi
sur l'indépendance en 2006 nous avions
avec Alain Vassel proposé une loi pour
essayer de régler ce ce problème là ce
que je regrette je regrette que au
moment de la création de la pas parce
que c'est surtout la pas laallocation
personnalisée d'autonomie qui plombe
aujourd'hui entre guillemets les
départements lorsque cet appâ a été
institué on n'a pas mis à côté les
recettes nécessaires pour y faire face
et donc on se tretrouve aujourd'hui dans
une impasse qu' va falloir régler
effectivement je remarque également que
lorsque nous avons donc fait la loi du
11 février 2005 pour les personnes
handicapées nous avons prévu de financer
la dépendance pour les personnes
handicapées tout simplement dans le
cadre de la création de la journée de
solidarité et donc il y a la recette qui
a été inscrite parallèlement certains
disquaujourd'hui il faudrait peut-être
une deuxème journée de solidarité je
l'ai dit dans mon rapport il n'est pas
impossible qu'il faille envisager une
deuxème journée de solidarité pour faire
face à l'ensemble des dépenses mais je
crois que que il faudra voir un petit
peu quand le projet de loi sur la
dépendance aura été déposé et que il
aura été examiner s'il faut aller plus
loin voilà très bien une toute dernière
question paul Blanc sur cette loi de
2005 vous avez fait voter ici au Sénat
sur les handicapés quel bilan vous en
faites aujourd'hui est-ce que ça a
vraiment amélioré la vie quotidienne des
personnes handicapées je crois que ça a
améliorer d'ailleurs toutes les
associations le reconnaissent en
particulier par la création de la maison
départementale du handicap c'est vrai
qu'il y a quelques dysfonctionnement
encore c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai présenté au Sénat une projet de loi
une PPL qui a été adopté par le Sénat le
20 octobre dernier ce texte doit passer
maintenant à l'Assemblée je pense que
après le passage à l'Assemblée on
arrivera à avoir un accord total qui
nous permettra d'avoir avancer aussi sur
cette problématique et de la même DPH
mais aussi quelques autres dispositions
qu'il faudra étudier notamment
concernant le fonctionnement de la gfip
et les CAP EMPLOI merci beaucoup euh
paul Blanc sénateur UMP des Pyrénées
orientale d'être venu sur cette antenne
nous accueillons maintenant toujours ici
dans la salle des conférences du Sénat
alors que dans quelques minutes va
reprendre la séance sur l'épineuse
question donc de l'amendement voté par
le Sénat et que conteste le gouvernement
sur euh l'allègement des charges pour
les personnes qui emploient des salariés
à domicile Raymond leexier qui est
sénatrice socialiste du valdoise madame
Le Texier bonsoir bonsoir euh donc on le
voit le gouvernement au nom finalement
de la rigueur budgétaire de 450 millions
d'euros qu'il ne faut pas finalement
supprimer dans les économies qui sont
recherchées aujourd'hui demande une
deuxième délibération au Sénat est-ce
que malgré tout l'équilibre qui est
trouvé qui maintient globalement les
exonérations d'impôt globales sur
l'emploi à domicile contte tenu de ces
impératifs qu'on retrouve parti en
Europe partout en Europe n'est pas
acceptable euh pas pour nous pas pour
nous parce que il s'agit là de de faire
une économie de
460 millions très bien on sait bien
qu'il faut absolument faire des
économies mais euh il faut rapprocher
ces 460 millions d'autres économies qui
ne sont pas faites c'est-à-dire des 3
milliards de de baisse de TVA au
restaurateur euh des niche Copé par
exemple de la niche Copé des heures
supplémentair sur les sessions de de
filiales d'entreprise voilà et là en
fait sur qui va-t-on faire ses économies
sur le dos de qui pas sur le dos de de
de personnes aisé qui emploi du
personnel de maison à temps plein on va
faire essentiellement les économies sur
des jeunes m de famille qui euh finance
euh le préposte scolaire et la cantine
pour le Grand qui va à l'école
élémentaire la crèche pour le petit et
une nounou à mi-temps parce que aucune
jeune femme travaillant en part
particulier en zone urbaine en
particulier en région parisienne où il y
a des temps de transport importants ne
peut être à la sortie de l'école ou à la
sortie de la crèche à l'heure donc ces
jeunes femmes on en connaît il y en a
plein la maison là parmi vos collègues
elles ont non seulement plein pot sur la
la crèche et surtout ce que je viens de
de vous dire mais de plus l'embauche
d'une nounou à mi-temps pour aller
chercher les enfants la sortie de
l'école la sortie de la class la
différence va pas être considérraable
puisquil y a la réduction d'impôts il y
en a aussi qui qui emploi sur la base
forfait TER et donc à ce momentl abent
et ben juste oui à ce momentl qui pement
justement alors ça va toucher les
personnes les employeurs qui déclarer
leur personnel sur au salaire réel donc
on va inciter de fait ces personnes-là
ces employeurs à déclaré maintenant leur
personnel sur la base forfaitaire qui
est quand même nettement moins
intéressante pour les salariés au moment
de de de la retraite donc moi je trouve
tout à fait dommage qu'on fasse des
économies sur les classes moyennes et
sur les jeunes couples c'est du une
mesquinerie à pleurer voilà alors en
même temps le Parti socialiste est en
train de faire adopter un texte sur
l'égalité réelle qui justement aborde
toutes ces questions sociales mais
auquel on reproche de de ne pas y
compris au sein de votre propre parti de
ne pas dresser une liste de priorités
comme si aujourd'hui dans votre
programme on pouvait encore tout faire
non non on peut pas tout faire et bien
sûr qu'il faut dresser la liste de
priorités mais on a un petit peu de
temps quand même on a un peu de temps
pour faire cette liste de de priorités
et et il y a des choses qui qui bougent
on c'est déjà plus ou moins où on va
aller mettre ses priorités mais je crois
que il faut pas chaque fois que on est
en opposition sur des mesures comme
cellees-ci comme sur l'article 90 que
l'on considère injuste nous amener à à
parler de nos insuffisances au niveau du
du programme si on était quand même
franchement vous le savez bien si on
était si nul que ça euh on gagnerait pas
pas ce que je dire vous le dites pas
mais c'est dit par d'autres on ne
gagnerait pas toutes les régions tous
les conseils généraux les les les
habitants nos électeurs ils savent bien
que qu'on s'est géré et qu'on est et
qu'on est des gens des gens sérieux et
c'est justement parce qu'on est des gens
sérieux que que voilà on regrette que
les cotisations sociales s'agissant des
familles dont je viens de de vous parler
surtout des jeunes couples soit une
augmentation de de 15 points j'ai le
ministre tout à l'heure a dit on touche
pas à certaines catégories les
handicapés les parents de handicapés les
enfants de handicapés les personnes
âgées dépendantes par exemple non non il
a dit les personnes de plus de 70 ans
vous voulez un scoop j'en fais partie
est-ce que vous croyez que je n'ai pas
les moyens de payer les charges sociales
de la dame qui m'aide à la maison et
bien j'ai 70 ans donc je ne suis pas
concerné par les 15 points de plus qui
concernent les jeunes mères de famille
pire que ça un mois après mon
anniversaire j'ai reçu une lettre du
césu me disant je leur demandais rien
nous avons le plaisir de vous annoncer
que compte tenu de votre grand âge dor
avant vos charges sociales vont baisser
s'agissant de votre femme de ménage
d'accord donc à 70 ans on paye moins de
chargees sociale déjà pour personnel
qu'on emploie on n'est pas concerné
comment c'est bien on a besoin de de
faire rentrer d'argent dans les de
l'argent dans les CAES de l'État c'est
bien pour les personnes de 70 ans qui
gagnent 3 franc 6 sous qui ont des
retraites de misère mais vous savez bien
qu'il y a aussi des retraités qui sont à
l'aise c'est le cas des nombreux
sénateurs qui ont plus de 70 ans et qui
sont dans cette maison j'en fais partie
donc vous vous seriez prêt à payer plus
à moi je suis prête à payer plus en
échange de de de ces jeunes couples qui
qui qui vont eux payer plus alors que
ils sont pour la plupart d'entre eux
moins àaise donc il faudrait cibler un
petit peu mieux les mesures CIBL et vous
savez très bien pourquoi c'est pas ciblé
et pourquoi on dispense les personnes de
70 ans parce que on sait statistiquement
que plus on vieillit plus on vot à
droite alors il faut protéger les
personnes de 70 ans même celles qui
gagnent bien leur vie ce qui est le cas
de mes collègues sénateurs mais vous
vous faites pas du tout 70 ans on vous
donne facilement 10 ans de moins voilà
merci en tout cas de d'être venu sur ce
merci de votre témoignage nous
accueillons jean-Pierre Fourcade
jean-Pierre Fourcade sénateur umpd haute
scène alors Monsieur Fourcade c'est
raisonnable ce que demande le
gouvernement en allant comme ça un peu
forcer la main du Sénat sur une deuxième
délibération tous les ministres des
finan à la fin d'un budget ont essay
sont revenus sur des amendements adoptés
contre l' viis du gouvernement pendant
la discussion pour une fois le
gouvernement ne nous demande de revenir
que sur un vote
je trouve que c'est pas mal monsieur
Barouin l'a faire marqué bon c'est une
affaire difficile parce que cette
réduction des charges sociales va gêner
non pas les particuliers qui vont passer
du système des frais réels au système
forfaitaire qui est un peu moins
favorable pour les salariés puisquil est
basé sur le le smins favorable pour les
salariés mais ça va beaucoup gêner les
associations qui ont recruté beaucoup de
monde pour s'occuper des personnes âgées
des enfants de la scolarité et cetera
estce qu'elles n'ont pas ce choix avec
le système forfaitaire bon quce qu'elles
n'ont pas ce choix avec le système
forfaitaire voilà moi je trouve qu'il
aurait fallu trouver pour 500 millions
des économies d'autant plus que les
économies de l'année prochaine l'année
prochaine en 2012 étant donné que la
déduction fiscale est
conservée l'avantage l'économie de 500
millions sera réduite de moitié à peu
près mais bon on avait propos les gens
vont basculer d'un système à l'autre
voilà on avait proposé d'autres système
le gouvernement nous demande de nous
rétracter sur un seul élément après une
discussion qui a duré 20 jours je trouve
que c'est raisonnable et c'est pour ça
que la commission des finances a accepté
de voter l'ensemble des amendements
proposés par le gouvernement et c'est un
budget qui n'est pas mauvais c'est le
début du retour à une gestion financière
solide le budget de l'année prochaine
sera beaucoup plus difficile il faudra
beaucoup plus de courage pour le faire
surtout à la veille d'une présidentielle
la veille d'une présidentielle il faudra
pas faire de cadeau mais je crois qu'on
est engagé dans la bonne voie on va
réduire notre déficit on va réduire
notre nos nos emprunts sur les marchés à
moyen et long terme et par conséquent je
crois qu'on va ça va dans le bon sens
juste un mot Jeanpierre fa l'impression
que ce débat en cache unre qui va être
très difficile aussi à droite parce que
déjà a beaucoup de d'avis différents sur
la réforme fiscale certains disent il
faut supprimer l'ISF c aprèsmi le
ministre bar dit on pourrait en garder
un petit bout sur la réforme fiscale le
gouvernement en en
organisant en
organisant la les commissions
parlementaire ne m'a pas fait signe il
considère que je n'ai pas de compétence
fiscale par conséquent je ne dirai rien
il a tort alors en fa voilà jean-Pierre
Fourcade qui rappelons-le est ancien
ministre de l'économie et des finances
lors du SEPA de Valérie Giscard destin
dans quelques minutes cette suspension
de séance qui a duré à mon avis bien
plus du quart d'heure voilà les
sénateurs sont pas toujours ponctuels
mais on peut penser que les discussions
ont été vives vont donc reprendre la
discussion sur cet amendement très
controversé sur lequel le gouvernement a
demandé une seconde délibération vous
avez entendu tout à l'heure le sénateur
centriste Hervé Morin Hervé Moret qui
est venu s'exprimer à notre métro à
notre micro pour indiquer que selon lui
il n'y avait pas de raison majeure que
les centristes ne reste pas sur leur
position qui consiste à joindre leur
voix à celle de l'opposition pour
maintenir la la position du Sénat en
faveur de la suppression euh de la
disposition voulue par le gouvernement
qui remet en cause des exonérations de
chargees sociale sur les employeurs de
personnes de salariés à domicile voilà
donc il se pourrait il se pourrait il
n'est pas impossible on va voir comment
les choses se présentent maintenant que
le gouvernement et suit un revers sur
cette question que les centristes
fassent entendre leur différence sur une
question euh social assez sensible qui
touche beaucoup de monde même si vous
l'avez vu euh bien sûr beaucoup
d'employeurs à domicile peuvent vont
continuer à bénéficier des réductions
fiscales peuvent aussi basculer d'un
mode de calcul à l'autre qui leur
permettra d'éviter de perdre cette de
cette ristourne sur les cotisations mais
qui sera peut-être moins favorable aux
salariés bref euh voilà dans la vie
quotidienne cette disposition n'a pas
forcément de conséquences considérable
hormis Jean-Pierre faucade le disait par
notamment pour les associations mais
elle est symboliquement et politiquement
très sensible alors il faut savoir que
si jamais le Sénat refusait au
gouvernement ce qu'il demande sur cet
article il y aura ensuite la commission
mixte paritaire chargée de trouver un
accord sur le projet de loi de finances
puis la dernière lecture dans chaque
assemblée et donc le gouvernement
pourrait encore obtenir gain de cause
mais ce serait un geste politique
relativement notable de la part du Sénat
après le vote de confiance accordé à
François Fillon qui montrerait que les
dissensions au sein de la majorité
notamment dans les relations avec euh
les centristes et vous savez qu'ici au
sein du groupe centriste euh on a à la
fois des proches euh de l'UMP du Nouveau
Centre et également des euh un certain
nombre de sénateur qui se réclament du
MoDem donc de François Baayou et bien
montrerait que les relations avec les
centristes restent compliquées
aujourd'hui euh pour le gouvernement de
de François Fillon on en SAA donc plus
dans quelques instants la séance devrait
euh reprendre je vois le le rapporteur
du budget euh Philippe mareni qui est
encore ici dans la salle des conférences
euh je pense que le ministre du Budget
françois Barouin va lui aussi rejoindre
l'hémicycle on aura donc le vote sur euh
cette disposition assez importante et
symbolique et puis on passera aux
explications de vote sur l'ensemble du
budget un vote qui euh maintenant a sans
doute pris un peu de retard mais qui
devrait euh Inter venir en début de
soirée probablement vers 19h 19h30
peut-être pendant l'édition que
présentera tout à l'heure Michel
grossior à signaler mais c'est une
formalité aujourd'hui qu'ici un petit
peu plus loin dans la salle des
conférences va avoir lieu aussi la
désignation d'un questeur les questeurs
du Sénat ce sont un peu les trésoriers
si vous voulez de la Haute Assemblée
ceux qui tiennent ceux qui contrôlent
les comptes de la Haute Assemblée vous
savez que le Parlement a sa propre
gestion des comptes et elle aura lieu
cet après-midi pour remplacer Philippe
Richert qui a été nommé membre du
gouvernement euh le rapporteur général
du budget Philippe marign est avec nous
bonjour bonjour euh Philippe Marini
est-ce que vous êtes optimiste ou est-ce
que vous pensez que le gouvernement va
obtenir gain de cause sur la deuxième
délibération qu'il demande concernant
cet article qui revoit à la baisse les
exonérations de charges pour les
employeurs de salariés à domicile oui
bien entendu bien entendu mais sous la
constitution de la 5e République à la
fin de l'examen du budget soit on prend
en bloc le texte avec les amendements
acceptés par le gouvernement soit on ne
prend pas le texteà direire on ne vote
pas le budget et malgré tout les
centristes disent qu'ils réservent
encore leur position parce que là ils
vont voter que sur cet article là
écoutez cela fait partie du jeu
parlementaire mais je n'ai vraiment pas
d'inquiétude sur le fond de la mesure
malgré tout un certain nombre de de
réserves ici au Sénat oui mais vous
savez il faut faire des économies les
économies sont douloureuses moi je ne
connais pas
d'économie la question c'est pas qu'elle
soit douloureuse qu'elle soit juste al
là ça va frapper on nous disait des
jeunes MRE de
famille on conserve un régime de
déduction fiscale qui est vraiment très
avantageux et qui est l'un des plus
coûteux en terme de dépenses fiscales et
quant aux cotisations sociales seront
payé et bien elles entreront dans les
dépenses déductibles au titre de l'impôt
sur le revenu certes avec un décalage
d'un an mais on n'aura pas tout perdu
les employeurs de ces salariés à
domicile seront loin d'avoir tout perdu
et continueront à bénéficier d'un régime
fiscal qui à mon avis est sensiblement
plus avantageux en France que dans bien
d'autres pays européens alors je crois
qu'il ne faut pas exagérer avec la
défense des intérêts particuliers même
légitime
que l'on veuille avoir ou garder le
maximum pour son métier ou son groupe
d'intérêt c'est très bien maintenant le
Parlement c'est pas une addition de
groupe d'intérêt n'est-ce pas et le
Parlement il vote en fonction d'une
situation économique donné il prend ses
responsabilités et nul ne peut imaginer
d'économie qui ne soit pas un peu
douloureuse car si elles ne sont pas
douloureuses tout simplement ce ne sont
pas des économies mais seulement de la
poudre aux yeux alors derrière ce débat
là on voit qui est assez passionné ou en
tout cas sur lequel il y a des positions
assez différentes des discussions même
on le voit avec les centriste il va y
avoir un nouveau débat fiscal en 2011 et
là on voit qu'au sein de la majorité il
y a des points de vue très très
différents sur la réforme fiscale cet
après-midi dans le monde françois
Barouin dit qu'il se pourrait très bien
de qu'on ne supprime pas l'impôt sur la
fortune de manière intégrale euh
d'autres dans la majorité sont réservés
sur la position prise par Nicolas
Sarkozi de ne pas créer en compensation
une tranche super rieur de l'impôt sur
le revenu quel est votre point de vue
sur ces dissensions internes au sein de
la majorité alors que çaannonce un débat
fiscal encore beaucoup plus large que
celui d'aujourd'hui je suis surpris
qu'on me parle de dissension on est dans
une phase préparatoire à l'examen d'un
texte il est bien
naturel que des idées et des techniques
différentes s'expriment ou alors
qu'est-ce que ça voudrait dire ça
voudrait dire que tout le monde est aux
ordres et le petit doigt sur la couture
du pantalon ce qui n'est pas le cas donc
il est parfaitement normal que même si
ce débat est bref c'est-à-dire de
l'ordre de 3 mois il est lieu c'est
parfaitement normal il faut que l'on
s'habitue à fonctionner comme ça bon
maintenant au bout du compte c'est là
aussi le Parlement qui prendra ses
responsabilités pour ma part je pense
que la dernière année de la législature
il est difficile de faire une telle
réforme mais que c'est utile et je
souhaite vivement que l'on y parvienne
je ne crois sincèrement pas pour ma part
que l'on puisse faire totalement
disparaître l'Impôt de Solidarité euh
sur la fortune en 2011 d'où euh les
idées que je partage avec françois
Barouin sur ce sujet vous savez j'ai des
idées j'ai des convictions mais je ne
suis pas un extrémiste je pense qu'à
chaque fois qu'on peut faire un petit
pas il faut le faire et qu'il faut
savoir faire des concessions pour
atteindre ses buts car immédiatement on
ne peut pas forcément aller au bout de
beaucoup critiqué l'ISF dans le passé
donc vous dites pas forcément le
supprimer intégralement dès l'année
prochaine je regarde la situation de
l'opinion je regarde la situation
économique je regarde les besoins des
finances publiques et je constate que
supprimer totalement cet impôt en 2011
c'est en effet une équation assez
redoutable et c'est mettre la barre très
très haut alors je crois qu'il y a des
formules
intermédiaires pour ma part je suis
également attaché à ce que l'impôt sur
le revenu puisse être examiné dans le
cadre de notre réflexion et que l'on ne
ferme pas avant que le débat n'ait lieu
la question de la tranche marginal
supplémentaire de l'impôse sur le revenu
donc nous ne pouvons pas considérer au
niveau parlementaire qu'une décision est
été prise sur ce sujet un dernier mot la
réconciliation entre madame betancour et
sa fille selon vous est - qu'elle va
avoir des conséquences sur les enquêtes
concernant Eric vert je ne suis ni
magistrat ni avocat je n'ai aucune
espèce de titre à connaître le dossier
je n'en sais strictement rien tout ce
que je dit c'est que mon ami Eric vert
s'est trouvé pris dans un feu croisé
où un endroit où il a pris les balles
perdues entre une mère et sa fille et
que c'est une bien triste situation et
que les responsabilités ne sont
certainement pas les siennes merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup Philippe Marini
je crois qu'on peut avoir une petite
seconde Jean arthu président de la
commission des finances qui va nous
donner en un petit instant avant de
rejoindre l'émicycle parce que ça va
reprendre
bientôt bah un petit peu la tonalité de
ce que vous êtes dit en commission des
finances monsieur
ui vousz venez d'entendre le rapporteur
général donc je pense que vous avez eu
ce qui s'est dit en commission des
finances et c'est un peu c'est toujours
une violence la deuxème délibération
revenir sur un vote mais dans le cas
particulier je crois qu'il y a eu
maldonne dans dans la discussion au
Sénat s'agissant euh de l'allégement de
15 points sur les cotisations des des
personnels qui travaillent à domicile
euh je pense que le Sénat a eu tort ça
s'est joué à deux voix de voter le
rétablissement euh de l'allèigement la
bonne mesure c'était probablement 10
points euh d'allègement et en
contrepartie et en contreparti un coup
de rabau sur le crédit d'impôt parce que
aujourd'hui alors d'abord il faut bien
faut bien souligner que ne sont pas
concernés les publics fragiles euh les
les les personnes qui travaillent pour
des enfants handicapés pour des
personnes âgées de plus de 70 ans pour
les bénéficiaires de la location
personnalisée d'autonomie pour les
bénéficiaires de la prestation
compensatrice du handicap donc vraiment
dédramatisons cette opération et au
surplu les les employeurs qui vont
perdre l'allègement de 15 points vont
donc payer un peu plus et payant un peu
plus ils bénéficieront d'une assiette de
crédit d'impôt plus importante autrement
dit le supplément de charge à la sortie
ne sera que de 50 %. oui donc ça veut
dire que la commission des finances va
suiv a émis majoritairement un avis
favorable pour l'approbation de cette
seconde délibération je rappelle quand
même que le Sénat a voté de très
nombreux amendements que le gouvernement
aurait souhaité une seconde délibération
pour revenir sur ces votes du
Sénat plus nombreux que cette seule
disposition relative à l'allègement de
cotisation sociale pour le personnel
travaillant à domicile et vos collèges
centristes je crois sont encore en train
de se réunir j'étais j'étais avec eux
j'étaisvec c'est grâce à certains
d'entre eux que la mesure est que
l'amendement du Sénat est passé alors
d'près oui mais fa seraisje dire que la
la la la démarche a peut-être manqué
d'un il y avait un geste à accomplir
mais la démarche a manqué un peu de
cohérence et puis je voudrais rappeler
quand même que l'objectif fondamental
c'est la réduction des déficits public
et que nous voyons au travers de cette
de cette mesure combien va être
difficile la réduction de la dépense
publique la réduction des dépenses
d'intervention la réduction des dépenses
de fonctionnement et et l'équilibre
budgétaire j'auraai l'occasion tout à
l'heure de dire à la tribune que le
compte n'y est pas merci beaucoup
jeanartui président de la commission des
finances nous accueillons encore le
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
Jean-Pierre belle bonsoir bonsoir
Jean-Pierre belle on vient d'entendre
Philippe Marini le président de la
commission des finances et le
rapporteur le rapporteur général et le
président de la commission des finances
Jean arthui nous dire que la commission
des finances allait proposer d'aller
dans le sens de ce que souhaite le le
gouvernement de cette deuxème
délibération pour revenir sur ce qui
avait été voté par le sén qui euh
supprimait la proposition du
gouvernement de de réduire les les les
baisses de charges he pour les employés
pour les employeurs de de salariés à
domicile euh donc c'est quasiment joué
maintenant
euh sur sur la méthode vous savez on
commence à être habitué ici au Sénat
avoir un gouvernement qui joue avec le
Sénat un peu comme il l'entend mais ça
c'est un classique hein les secondes
délibération c'est les secondes
délibérations depuis quelques tards en
effet sur des textes qui sont des textes
difficiles
ça devient un classique mais est-ce que
est-ce que c'est bien dans le fond une
assemblée s'exprime un vote intervient
et il y a une sorte de rappel à l'ordre
parce que vous savez une seconde
délibération ça s'accompagne toujours
d'une grande discussion au sein de la
majorité et nous savons que dans les
palais présidentiels le gouvernement
lui-même dispose de moyens pour
convaincre les quelques récalcitran qui
dans un premier temps se sont cru
inspirés en votant peut-être
différemment voilà des centristes qui
ont joint leur voix celle de
l'opposition moi je ne voudrais pas
aujourd'hui être euh centriste de la
majorité parce que ce sont des
centristes appartenant à la majorité qui
à tout bout de champ se voit dans le
fond des avoués et il sont obligés de de
de faire marche arrière je j'aimerait
pas être vraiment à leur place et je
sais que certains le vivent le vivent
assez mal donc c'est un commentaire que
je fais sur la méthode mais après tout
chacun est légitime est inspiré par le
mandat qui qui a été é confié par les
électeurs céit un devoir quoi l'économie
réalisée représente un enjeu quand même
de 450 millions d'euros tout à l'heure
jeun n disait bah on est dans une
période où il faut absolument réduire le
le déficit budgétaire est-ce que vous
pouvez passer par j'allais dire perte
des profits c'est pas le cas
mais c'est dans un sens ou dans l'autre
une mesure qui justement est un élément
du dispositif budgétaire pour réduire
les déficits vous savez que parce qu'il
faut regarder les choses globalement
nous nous avons dénoncé cette espèce de
fausse réduction des déficits annoncés
euh puisque quand on regarde bien dans
le fond le déficit de la France restera
important mais sur ce point particulier
des emploissices vous savez très bien
comment ils ont été créés dans quel
contexte ils ont été créés pour lutter
contre le travail au noir ça permet
aussi un certain nombre de de personnes
de trouver un statut voilà je pense que
le coûp de rabot euh général est quand
même particulièrement injuste j'aurais
préféré qu'on regarde niche par niche et
qu'on puisse se faire une idée de ce qui
est équitable et de ce qui ne l' pas ce
n'est pas le cas dans ce budget
aujourd'hui je le regrette merci
beaucoup Jean-Pierre B je vous laisse
rejoindre l'émicycle où la séance vient
de reprendre on va tout de
suite entendre le président de la
commission rapporteur général du budget
Philippe Marini qui donne donc son avis
favorable à la demande du
gouvernementis à deè
délibération conformément à la demande
de vote unique je vais mettre au voix
les
amendements numéro B1 à
B24 ainsi que les articles 48 et état B
90 et 47 et état a
explication de
vote monsieur maçon monsieur maçon ver
c'est pas c'est pas le vote sur
l'ensemble hein je rappelle que ça n'est
pas le vote sur l'ensemble mais
uniquement sur cette partie appelée en
seconde délibération
euh monsieur le Président par principe
moi je je suis partisan d'une véritable
démocratie et je crois que ce n'est pas
sain d'avoir des systèmes de de vote
bloqué du type selon selon lequel on les
a je crois qu'il y a dans les dans les
amendements qui nous sont soumis il y a
des des points qui me paraissent très
importants notamment les dégrèvements
sur pour l'emploi de salariés à domicile
moi je comprends que le gouvernement
veille faire des économies parce que la
France est dans une situation
désastreuse mais qui l'a mis dans une
situation désastreuse qui a réduit les
impôts qui a supprimé la TVA sur les
restaurateurs qui a supprimé la taxe
professionnelle par ailleurs par
ailleurs par ailleurs je
voudrais bon voilà par ailleurs je
voudrais je voudrais dire je voudrais
dire également que si l'on voulait
récupérer de l'argent et bien pour cette
année il y avait une solution très
simple c'était de supprimer le bouclier
fiscal donc je suis radicalement en
désaccord avec ce n proposé je voterai
contre
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègu quelques observations formelles
tout d'abord sur cette seconde
libération cette loi de finan 2011 a
fait l'objet de plus de 1 millier
d'amendements
entre la partie recette et la partie
crédit de la part de la Commission des
membres des groupes politiques et même
du
gouvernement conclusion provisoire assez
peu d'amendements en dehors de ceux
déposés au nom de la commission par le
rapporteur général et ce proposé en
dernière minute par le gouvernement ont
été adoptés et adjoints au
texte mais malgré tout cette nouvelle
seconde délibération après celle de
l'Assemblée nationale vient réduire
encore un peu plus l'apport du travail
parlementaire à sa plus simple
expression ex avant même que la
commission mixte paritaire ne procède
sans doute à un nouvel ajustement du
texte cela témoigne mes chers collègues
d'un profond mépris du travail des
parlementaire et de notre assemblée et
cela témoigne une nouvelle fois d'une
volonté de remettre en cause le rôle et
les droits du Parlement c'est donc
l'article 90 relatif aux emplois dit
familiaux qui fait l'objet de
laattention gouvernementale sans que ne
soit d'ailleurs remis en cause le champ
d'application de la réduction d'impôt
qui profite très largement aux familles
les plus fortunées quand il s'agit de
payer leurgent de maison et c'est sans
doute au cours de la commission mixte
paritaire que l'on que l'on s'occupera
du reste c'est-à-dire
de taxer les malades étrangers
sollicitant l'aide médicale d'État ou
d'imposer la disparition de la publicité
à France Télévision le tout conduisant à
ne faire varier qu'à la marge le contenu
de la loi de finance
initiale sur le fond maintenant les
objectifs affichés de cette loi de
finance ne sont pas atteints la
réduction du déficit est en effet
purement optique et procède plus de la
disparition des mesures du plan de
relance que d'une véritable lutte contre
le gaspillage des ressources publiques
que nous observons depuis des années les
mesures qu'il faudrait prendre ne sont
toujours pas au rendez-vous et
l'équilibre général de l' finance n'est
pas mis en question on reste sur le
principe de mettre à contribution les
couches moyennes qui paieront un peu
plus d'impôts et on éparne largement les
plus hauts revenus et les patrimoines
pour les plus modestes les plus
vulnérables pas de hausse d'impôt bien
entendu mais simplement moins de dép
publi c'est-à-dire moins de solidarité
moins de service rendu moins de réponse
aux besoins sociaux et bien pour toutes
ces raisons notre groupe communiste
républicain citoyens et sénateur du
parti gauche ne votera évidemment pas
cette seconde
délibération d'autres demandes
d'explication de
vote je n'en vois point je
soumets donc maintenant au vote ceux qui
sont favorables le manifeste en levant
la main
7 73
74 prè 75 à peu près avis
contraire ch des quand
5 70 alors on va vérifier par assis et
debout ceux qui sont favorables se
lèv qui vient d'arriver
il y a un autre qui vient d'arriver deux
autres il y en a deux autres qui VI
d'arriver
3 un
a rom
arriv
merci ceux qui sont
contre
c'est
adoptéation
quoi
bien mes chers collègues conformément à
la décision de la Conférence des
Présidents et vaborder avant d'aborder
les explications de vote sur l'ensemble
du projet de lo de finance nous allons
maintenant procéder à l'élection d'un
questeur du Sénat en remplacement de
Monsieur Philippe
Richer le groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire a présenté la candidature de
Monsieur Gérard Derot en application de
l'article 61 de notre règlement cette
élection aura lieu au scrutin secret et
se déroulera dans la salle des
conférences je rappelle qu'au terme de
l'alinéa 2 de l'article 52 du règlement
si la majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés n'a pas été acquise aux deux
premiers tours la majorité relative
suffit au 3e tour en cas d'égalité des
chiffrages le plus âgé est nommé le
scrutin sera ouvert pendant 1 he je vais
prier madame
deessine et Madame Sy des
Maresco secrétaire du Sénat de bien
vouloir présider le bureau de vote et de
superviser les opération de
dépouillement le scrutin pour l'élection
d'un questeur du Sénat est
ouvert je vais maintenant passer si vous
le voulez bien aux explications de
vote sur l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financeces pour
avant de
procéder au vote sur
l'ensemble
donc je vais donner la parole à ceux de
nos collègues qui l'ont demandé
j'indique au Sénat que compte tenu de
l'organisation des débats décidé par la
Conférence des
Présidents chacun des groupesose de 10
minutes et la Réunion administrative des
sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe de 5
minutes la parole est tout d'abord au
président de la commission des finances
Monsieur Jean
harui salut
Jean monsieur le
Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues jamais je le crois la
discussion
budgétaire que nous allons clore dans
quelques instants n'aura autant mérité
le qualificatif de marathon budgétaire
que l'on accoutume de lui
donner nous pouvions penser que le
budget pour 2011 se déroulerait en e
calme après la tempête de 2010 qui avait
vu la discussion d'un véritable projet
de loi dans le projet de loi avec la
suppression de la taxe
professionnelle nous aurons en réalité
siégé presque autant d'heures qu'en
2009 alors que nous avons anticipé cette
année au début du mois de novembre les
débats thématiques que nous avions
l'habitude d'organisé en première partie
quant au nombre d'amendements il a
dépassé la barre symbolique des 1000 que
nous n'avions pas réussi à atteindre
l'an dernier ce constat est d'abord la
preuve du dynamisme du Sénat et de ses
membres la preuve de leur profonde
implication dans la recherche des
solutions au problèmes que doit
affronter la France
aujourd'hui l'expression de leur volonté
de conférer toute sa place au Parlement
dans cet indispensable travail de
réflexion qui doit nous rendre plus fort
et plus confiant dans un monde ouvert en
pleine mutation la commission des
finances s'en félicite et je remercie
vivement les 46 rapporteurs spéciaux les
66 rapporteurs pour avis des CIN autres
commissions sans oublier bien sûr la
commission des affaires européennes et
vous tous mes chers collègues qui avez
enrichi nos débats de vos analyses de
vos questions et de votre expérience de
femmes et d'hommes de terrain une
nouvelle fois je le crois chers
collègues le Sénat a très bien assumé sa
mission cependant je sou vous rendre
attentif à la contrainte incontournable
parce que constitutionnel qui s'impose à
nous une loi de finidance doit être
examinée et voté dans un délai de 20
jours pas un de moins mais pas un de
plus non plus il s'agit non d'un
impératif arbitraire destiné à bayonner
la libre expression du Parlement mais
d'un gardefou permettant de s'assurer
que le budget pourra bien être mis en
uvre
dès le début de l'exercice qui s'ouvre
cet impératif il nous revient d'en tenir
compte dans l'intérêt même du
fonctionnement normal de nos
institutions certains d'entre vous ont
pu à bon droit
s'étonner des mesures drastique
d'aménagement de l'ordre du jour que
nous avons dû prendre en coordination
avec la présidence et le gouvernement et
qui nous ont conduit à repousser en fin
de discussion l'examen d'une partie des
articles rattachés mais mes chers
collègues ces mesures étaient
indispensables dès lors que nous
voulions parvenir à Bonport dans les
délais impartis incontestablement il
nous faudra prolonger dès les prochains
mois la réflexion déjà entamée sur
l'organisation le déroulement du débat
budgétaire mais je souhaite d'ors et
déjà alerter le gouvernement sur le fait
qu'il est périlleux monsieur le ministre
pour ne pas dire franchement inopportun
de multiplier les articles rattachés qui
relève plus à mon sens d'un projet de
loit portant diverses dispositions
d'ordre financier économique social
environnemental touristique culturel que
sais-je que de lois de finan ce budget
aura été celui du record du nombre de
rattachés je souhaite que cette
véritable erreur de je n'hésite pas à le
dire ne se reproduisent pas sauf à
devoir recourir à nouveau à des procédés
qui sont des sources inutile de
frustration pour le Sénat j'en viens au
fond du texte la commission des finances
vous proposera certes de l'adopter dans
quelques instants mais après une mise en
garde que je veux solennelle monsieur le
ministre car l'heure est grave et exige
une prise de conscience dont gestime
qu'elle n'est pas encore complète au
risque de répéter ce que j'ai déjà
affirmé en introduction de nos
discussions voici 3 semaines je veux ici
rappeler que la France doit rompre
rompre avec son addiction à la dépense
publique si elle veut retrouver le
chemin du retour à l'équilibre de ces
comptes publics ce budget mes chers
collègues répond-il à cette
exence et bien en conscience je n'en
suis pas pleinement convaincu près des 2
tiers de l'amélioration du solde du
budget de l'État en 2011 résulteront
d'économies de constatation né à lié à
la non reconduction des dépenses du Plan
Campus et aux investissements d'avenir
et le relic s'explique pour une large
part par le contrecout de la fin du plan
de relance et de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle l'évolution spontanée
des recetes en phase de reprise de
l'activité fait le reste les dépenses
d'intervention et de fonctionnement
auraient dû commencer à diminuer
franchement le mouvement convenons-en
n'est que pour l'instant timidement
ébauché nous prolongerons nos débats
dans quelques jours avec l'examen du
traditionnel collectif de fin d'année
je suis au regret de devoir d'ors et
déjà faire le constat que ce projet de
loi de finance rectificative signera
notre échec patent à endiguer les
dérapages de dépenses
inquiétants certains sont certes
conjoncturel lié à la crise comme la
multiplication des contrats ad mais
d'autres revê un caractère clairement
structurel comme l'Allocation Adulte
handicap
les aides au logement les opérations
extérieures et que dire de
l'augmentation continue de la masse
salariale en dépit à moins que ce soit à
cause des suppressions d'emploi elles
font en objet en effet l'objet ces
suppression d'emplois de concession
catégorielles sous forme de primes
diverses le budget qui nous est proposé
et qu'il faut lire à la lumière de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques est ainsi une assez timide
exquise d'un paysage dont les traits
devront sans doute être mieux dessinés
et affirmés dans le cadre de nos
échéances de l'an prochain je veux
redire ici ma conviction que nous
n'échapperons pas non plus à une
réflexion sur l'architecture de nos
prélèvements obligatoires une autre loi
de finances rectificative nous est
annoncé avant l'été prochain plus
spécifiquement consacré à la fiscalité
du patrimoine je me réjouis donc du
rendez-vous que nous donne le
gouvernement je me réjouis de sa volonté
de
concertation et je l'assure de ma totale
liberté de parole et de ton dans les
propositions que je lui ferai et dont il
connaît déjà certaines avant de conclure
mes chers collègues je souhaiterais me
faire votre porte-parole en adressant
mes très chaleureux remerciement à
Philippe Marini notre rapporteur général
qui a son habitude a mis son talent et
la force de ses convictions au service
du Sénat et même si quelquefois ces
explications sont un peu longues c'est
parce qu'il a c'est parce qu'il a la
volonté de permettre à chacun d'entre
nous de disposer des éléments de
compréhension pour se prononcer en
connaissance de cause et être en
situation de retour dans nos
départements d'ex ce que nous avons voté
soyez remercier monsieur le rapporteur
général je veux aussi saluer les
ministres dont le plus grand nombre est
venu débattre dans notre hémicycle
engageant avec les élus de tout bord un
dialogue républicain fait de respect
mutuel au-delà des différences légitimes
de point de vue et d'appréciation vous
me permettrez d'adresser une mention
particulière à Monsieur à Madame
la ministre de l'économie des finances
et de l'industrie qui ne peut pas être
parmi nous hélas cet après-midi ainsi
qu'à vous-même monsieur le ministre à
votre secrétaire d'État George Tron qui
était là il y a quelques instants à
Philippe Richert notre collègue à qui
nous devons une élection d'un nouveau
questeur en cet instant et remercier
aussi Patrick olier le ministre chargé
des relation avec le Parlement merci
pour votre très grande disponibilité
pour votre compréhension vos réponses
aux interrogations qui ont traversé
notre hémicycle mes remerciements vont
bien évidemment aussi à l'ensemble de
vos collaborateur monsieur le ministre
ceux de votre cabinet ainsi qu'aux
services qui ont à nouveau prouvé leur
efficacité et leur grande réactivité je
remercie enfin la présidence vous
monsieur le président du Sénat nos
collègues h vice-présidents les 14
secrétaires qui nous ont accompagné
ainsi que les service de la séance et
des compte-rendus grâce auxquels cette
discussion a pu rester dans les limites
que nous avions tracé mes derniers mots
seront pour
exprimer ma gratitude très profonde aux
collaborateurs de nos commission
permanente et particulièrement si vous
me le permettez à ceux de la commission
des finances je vous remercie mes chers
collègues de votre attention merci
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur général
de la commission des finances Monsieur
Philippe
Marini monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
488 amendements présentés au titre de la
première
partie
595 au titre de la seconde partie et
nous voici dans les temps au terme de ce
processus comme l'a indiqué très
justement Jean artui chacune et chacun
s'est efforcé d'y participer et au
premier chef les membres du gouvernement
avec qui le dialogue a été
constructif je n'ai pas fait de
recensement
exhaustif de nos votes mais je voudrais
rappeler que comme à
l'ordinaire la commission s'était forcé
de défricher
d'expliciter de trouver parfois les
juste
compromis et de permettre au Sénat de
bien expliciter ses
votes sur toute une série de sujets
monsieur le ministre nous n'avons pas
hésiter à voter contre la vie du
gouvernement
mais souvent grâce à la subtilité de vos
réponses nous avons
senti qu'il y avait plusieurs nuances
dans les avis que vous
exprimiez et j'ajouterai mes chers
collègues de l'opposition que
malgré un propos inexact que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure un grand nombre
d'amendements issus de vos groupes a été
adoptés souvent avec le soutien de la
Commission ou avec des avis de
sagesse chacune et chacun a joué son
rôle et bien entendu au premier chef la
majorité car chacun le sait pour avancer
il faut une
majorité
alors la commission mixte paritaire
chers collègues comme à l'ordinaire sera
bien préparé
et
heureusement les habitudes de travail
entre les deux rapporteurs généraux à
l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat
d'assurer cette préparation et
d'effectuer le tri de ce qui nous semble
devoir être maintenu dans les versions
adoptées d'un côté par l'Assemblée
nationale et de l'autre par le Sénat
dans le passé nous y sommes toujours
parvenus dans le respect la plupart du
temps des votes du Sénat et il n'y a
aucune espèce de raison de penser que
cette pratique cette jurisprudence ne
vont pas s'appliquer à nouveau pour la
loi de finances pour
2011 alors bien entendu lorsqu'on vote
un texte il y a des sujets de
satisfaction et il y a des sujets
d'insatisfaction nous savons très bien
que notre législation n'est pas parfaite
que la loi de finance n'est pas parfaite
je suis de ceux qui auraient souhaité
plus de mesures d'économie je suis de
ceux qui auraient souhaité un rabot
encore plus robuste sur une surface
encore plus large
mais je pense que le résultat obtenu et
dans l'ensemble un résultat qui fait
honneur à notre majorité car chacun le
sait Mesdames et Messieurs chers
collègues faire des économies c'est
difficile réduire les déficits c'est
difficile et il n'existe certainement
pas de mesure d'économie qui soit une
vraie mesure d'économie et qui par
ailleurs soit complètement indolor il
n'existe certainement pas de mesures
d'économie que ce soit sur les dépenses
budgétaires ou sur les dépenses fiscales
et qui ne suscite pas son cortège
d'intérêt particulier s'exprimant par le
lobbying jusque sous les ors et les
tentures de notre salle des conférences
ceci est une réalité que nous
connaissons et qui à la vérité est
connue par toutes les grandes
démocraties mais nous devons et nous
sommes certainement capables de nous
placer au-dessus de ces intérêts
particulierers car nous savons et en
particulier sous la 5e République que la
somme arithmétique des intérêts
particuliers ne fait certainement pas un
intérêt général et l'intérêt général
monsieur le ministre nous nous sommes
efforcés de le déterminer ensemble
compte tenu des contraintes de la
situation alors nous allons dans
quelques jours aborder la troisème
partie on peut l'appeler ainsi
c'est-à-dire la loi de finance
rectificative qui d'ailleurs dans notre
que depuis d'assez nombreuses années ne
rectifie plus grand-chose du budget de
l'année en cours certes elle rectifie
mais en réalité elle rectifie la loi de
finance que l'on vient tout juste de
voter sur toute une série de dispositifs
nous allons aborder cela avec
naturellement l'esprit le plus
constructif et à vos côtés monsieur le
ministre du Budget je terminerai en
rappelant que sur une série de sujets
nous nous sommes efforcés de AG des des
solutions pour l'avenir financement de
l'Agence nationale de renouvellement
urbain sort à réserver à l'aide à la
pierre et au logement social nous nous
sommes efforcés en ce domaine notamment
grâce à notre rapporteur spécial
philippe Dallier de faire prévaloir une
vision équilibré et ceci également grâce
à une nouvelle source en
île-de-fance s'agissant des questions de
finances local en effet et c'est le rôle
du Sénat nous avons complété la réforme
de la taxe professionnelle nous avons
mis en place pour la première fois un
dispositif de péréquation des droits de
mutation dont bénéficient les conseils
généraux et nous avons approfondi la
réflexion en ce qui concerne les autres
aspects de la
péréquation je crois que nos
contributions sont utiles et bien
souvent elles ont été exprimées de
manière assez consensuelle au sein de
notre haute assemblée pour l'avenir bien
d'autres débat naturellement nous
attendent débat fiscal en particulier
s'agissant de
l'imposition du patrimoine mais chacun a
sa conception du patrimoine et le
ministre lancer les
réflexions nous aurons dans les semaines
qui viennent
l'opportunité de définir ce que l'on
appelle patrimoine de définir le champ
de l'exercice et de rechercher la juste
position pour les propositions qui
seront faites au printemps au
Parlement n'oublions pas que dans la
situation économique qui est la nôtre la
du travail la mobilité du capital
prévale et que l'impératif de
compétitivité figure au tout premier
rang de même que celui d'équité et
d'efficacité de notre système fiscal
c'est donc sous ces trois maîtres mots
de
compétitivité
d'équité et
d'efficacité que je conclurai ce propos
en de votre attention merci monsieur le
rapporteur
général pour expliquer son vote et pour
minutes la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Louis maçon pour les
nonincrits ça va comme oui
oui
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues j'ai décidé de m'abstenir sur
ce budget parce que certaines
orientations ne me conviennent pas du
tout
euh depuis un certain nombre d'années la
France est confrontée à un déficit
budgétaire considérable et je pense que
quand on est confronté un état c'est
comme un ménage quand on est confronté à
un déficite budgétaire on commence par
faire deux choses c'est c'estd d'une
part essayer de dépenser trop d'argent
et d'autre part essayer de de gagner je
dirais le plus d'argent possible or
depuis que le Président de la République
est allé Élysée l'actuel président de la
République est allé éélysée on a passé
son temps à réduire les recettes de
l'État à diminuer les ressources de
l'État alors il y a eu la loi TPA il y a
eu les disons la TVA sur les
restaurateurs il y a eu la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle et je dis en
passant je tiens à souligner en passant
que quand on nous a présenté la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
on a dit ça coûterait simplement
quelques milliards or je viens
d'apprendre que le rapporteur du budget
à l'Assemblée nationale trouve qu'on est
passé de 3 ou 4 milliards estimé du coûp
de la réforme à 7 milliards et on n pas
et ce n'est pas fini alors la question
que je pose et bien quand on a un
président de la République qui dit il
faut s'inspirer des Allemands faut faire
comme les Allemands et cetera bon d'AB
d'abord première réflexion il est quand
même là depuis un certain temps il
aurait pu s'en rendre compte un peu plus
tôt et deuxièmement on ne prend pas le
chemin de faire ce que font les
Allemands car les Allemands depuis un
certain nombre d'années ont pris des
mesures sérieuses ont fait des efforts
considérable non pas jeter l'argent par
les fenêtres par tout un tas de
détaxation de suppression d'impôts comme
on l'a vu avec l'actuelle politique qui
est conduite alors c'est la première
raison qui m'amène moi à à dire que je
ne peux pas voter ce budget et d'autre
part je considère que les orientations
budgétaires fiscales sont des
orientations qui vont complètement à
l'encontre de la justice fiscale et de
l'équité fiscale moi il est plus
question pour moi de voter un budget où
on conserve le bouclier fiscal quand on
voit l'actualité récente quand on voit
que disons des super super millionnaires
qui étaient censé profiter du bouclier
fiscal pour ne pas mettre leur argent à
l'étranger non
seulement ils ont profité du bouclier
fiscal avec des millions d'euros empoché
chaque année mais en plus ils continuent
à mettre leur argent à l'étranger alors
moi je demande je pose la question oui
c'est pas des millionnaires c'était des
milliardaires bien moi je pose la
question quand on a des des gens qui
disons peuvent distribuer non pas des
millions d'euros mais j'ai en écoutant
la radio tout à l'heure c'était des
milliards d'euros quand on a quand on
peut distribuer un photographe un
milliard d'euros je vois pas pourquoi on
peut pas payer le bouclier fiscal bon et
je pense je pense pour ma part je pense
pour ma part que aussi bien face à la
loi sur les retraites que face à un
certain nombre de décisions difficiles
qui sont prises il n'est pas pensable de
demander à nos concitoyens de base de
faire des efforts si dans le même temps
et bien la politique qui est conduite et
qui est impulsée depuis l'Élysée est une
politique qui favorise systématiquement
les gens les plus favorisés et qui ne
prend pas en compte les problèmes des
gens qui rencontrent des difficultés
donc pour ces raisons euh j'ai décidé de
m'abstenir et je tiens à le dire ce
n'est pas la première fois que je que je
ne que je m'abstiens sur le budget pour
ma part il est hors de question de voter
un budget de de à l'avenir où on naurait
pas supprimé le bouclier
fiscal merci mon cher
collègue la parole est maintenant au
président IVau Collin pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique social et
européens monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues à
l'occasion de la discussion générale
j'ai exprimé un certain nombre de doutes
quant à la crédibilité la pertinence et
enfin l'équité du projet de loi de
finances pour 2011 vous ne sererez donc
pas surpris si je vous dise aujourd'hui
que ces doutes n'ont pas été levés
depuis malgré la qualité des échanges
que nous avons eu au cours de toutes ces
journées et toutes ces longues nuits de
débat monsieur le ministre vous ne tirez
pas les leçons du passé en fondant ce
budget pour 2011 sur une hypothèse de
croissance bien trop élevé j'aimerais
partager j'aimerais partager votre
optimisme sur la prévision de 2 % de
croissance mais vous savez très bien que
la moyenne des prévisions du groupe
d'experts relativ à la croissance
française est de 15,53 % et que
l'embellie ne tient en grande partie
qu'à une consommation soutenue par les
déficits publics par ailleurs nous ne
sommes pas à l'abri de nouvelles
tensions obligataire bancairire et
boursière si l'activité économique se
ralentit au cours des prochains mois
cela ne sera pas notutre en terme de
recette fiscale semblez-vous monsieur le
ministre l'oublier et je pense que ce ne
sont pas les choix que vous avez opéré
en terme de dépenses qui vont soutenir
l'activité du pays si on peut comprendre
votre volonté de faire glisser le
déficit public de 7,7 % à 6 % en 2011 on
peut néanmoins vous reprocher de vous
abriter derrière la norme zéro volume
désormais complété par la zone zéro
valeur pour pratiquer des coupes sombres
sur des missions dont les actions sont
pourtant
essentielles à la cohésion économique et
sociale de notre pays je pense en
particulier à l'éducation nationale dont
les suppressions de postes conduisent
des directeurs d'école à se transformer
en recruteurs pour boucler pour boucher
les trous en matière de logement vous
n'avez pas hésité à ponctionner les HLM
cher à notre collègue Thierry repenté la
sécurité pourtant une des priorités du
candidat Sarkozi VO crit fondre alors
que la violence aux personnes continue
d'augmenté sur le terrain la fermeture
de commissariat et d'antenne de quartier
est très mal vécu vous le saz savez par
nos concitoyens mais aussi par les élus
locaux ce sont ces mêmes élus locaux qui
doivent jongler avec des moyens de plus
en plus restreint et une autonomie
fiscale de plus en plus réduite alors
que les collectivités locales vous le
savez représentent un investisseur
public essentiel et qu'elles sont aussi
le pivot de l'aide sociale le gel de
leur dotation pour 3 ans est un mauvais
choix et de surcroix une atteinte aux
libertés locales quant à la péréquation
dont nous avons débattu longuement tout
à l'heure péréquation des ressources
cela reste un doux rêve et une fois de
plus le principe d'équité me semble mise
à mal il en va des collectivités comme
des particuliers la justice fiscale
exige de remettre à plat notre système
d'imposition pour permettre une vraie
une véritable redistribution des revenus
le sort que vous avez réservé à
certaines niches fiscales n'est pas de
nature à bouleverser architecture
budgétaire qui continue de pénaliser il
faut le dire les plus modestes et
surtout aussi les classes moyennes
certains de nos amendements comme celui
du RDSE rétablissant l'abattement de 15
% sur les cotisations sociales des
particuliers employeurs était destiné à
encourager l'emploi et la prise en
charge des plus fragiles il a été adopté
par le Sénat avant qu'une seconde
délibération ne viennent remettre en
cause ce vote la multiplication
d'ailleurs des secondes délibérations
monsieur le ministre Bafou le droit du
Parlement c'est décidément une manie une
étonnante manie d'ailleurs de la part
d'un gouvernement qui nous a expliqué en
2008 à versaill toute la place qu'il
comptait réserver au droits des
assemblées parlementaires dans la
Constitution mais chers collègues parce
que le PACT républicain est une nouvelle
fois malmené dans ce projet de loi de
finance parce que le gouvernement ne
s'attaque pas fondamentalement aux
injustices et à l'afférisme qui
gangraineent notre société et
marginalise de plus en plus de Français
la majorité des des membres du RDSE et
l'ensemble des Radicaux de Gauche se
prononceront contre ce projet de loi de
finance enfin monsieur le Président au
terme de ce marathon budgétaire qui a
suivi les textes sur les retraites et le
PLFSS je tiens au nom de mon groupe à
remercier et à féliciter l'ensemble de
nos collaborateurs et plus largement
l'ensemble du personnel du Sénat avec
une mention très spécial pour les
services du compte-rendu pour lesquels
les conditions de travail ne vont pas
s'améliorant et qui nous offrent malgré
ses difficultés un parfait reflet de la
vie colorée et animée de notre assemblée
il mérite eux vos
applaudissements
merci la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Emine montesc pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique social et
européen et pour 5
minutes vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues plus
encore que les années précédentes la
discussion budgétaire aurait été longue
et
éprouvante voici enfin venu le moment du
vote de la loi MRE décidant des moyens
d'action financiers de l'État ce projet
de loi de finances vise à relever un
double
défi ralentir la progression de la dette
et réduire le déficit de 60
milliards le rabot fiscal aura été pour
y parvenir un un outil essentiel
nécessaire et parfois très douloureux
les dépenses fiscales diminueront de 500
millions en 2011 2,7 milliards en 2012
et de 3,6 milliards en
2013 il faudrait bien sûr comme le
souhaite le rapporteur général
aller encore plus loin de la réduction
de la dépense sur la période
2011-24 la règles retenu pour
l'indexation des dépenses de l'État
incluant les concours aux collectivités
territorial et à l'Union européenne mais
excluant les pensions des agents publics
et les intérêts de la dette se
perfectionne en tenant compte de
l'inflation et d'une stabilisation à
périmètrre
Constant la paliss aurait pu le dire
d'autant que nous nous ne parviendrons
pas à l'équilibre budgétaire sans un
effort partagé entre la réduction de la
dépense et le maintien des
recettes depuis des années la commission
des finances du Sénat à l'initiative du
président artui du rapporteur général
Marini et défendu entre autres par votre
serviteur prône l'adoption de son fameux
triptique suppression de l'ISF
suppression du bouclier fiscal création
d'une 5è tranche ô son objectif une plus
grande justice sociale et fiscale cette
idée tellement séduisante qu'elle mérite
une longue réflexion selon le rapporteur
général carz pénètre progressivement
dans les esprits y compris dans ce des
ministres le triptique est même devenu
une tétralogie en ajoutant les revenus
du patrimoine quelle est votre position
monsieur le ministre ne pensez-vous pas
monsieur le ministre que proposition de
la commission des finances aurait pu
être mise en œuvre plus tôt le terme de
sagesse souvent employé pour le Sénat
n'est pas un hasard visant à accorder
toute sa place au Parlement la récente
réforme constitutionnelle devait devait
se traduire avant tout par plus de
considération pour les propositions des
parlementaires et en l'espèce celle des
commissaires des finances en matière
budgétaire peut-être pourriez-vous
désigner un volontaire pour étudier nos
recommandations le président de la
République lui-même mesure bien la
pertinence de nos travaux en imaginant
un projet de réforme profond
indispensable et consensuel de notre
fiscalité projet fondés sur notre
tétralogie par ailleurs l'idée de
rapprocher les systèmes fiscaux des pays
de la zone euro en particulier français
allem va assurément dans le bon sens
mais il faudra beaucoup d'intelligence
et
d'abnégation pour harmoniser des
systèmes aussi éloignés
qu'effroyablement complexes quelle
méthode comptez-vous mettre en œuvre
pour atteindre cet
objectif la comparaison de notre
fiscalité et notamment de nos
prélèvement obligatoire à celle de nos
voisins représente indiscutablement une
voix à suivre car nombre de nos débats
l'ont bien montré au cours de cette loi
de finances le duming fiscal entraîne
déstabilisation de l'euro perte de
contivité la liste est longue des mots
qu'il fait subir à notre économie à cet
égard il est fort dommage que les
recommandations du président de l'or en
faveur d'un rapprochement de nos
fiscalités et des politiques communes
n''est pas été entendu en leur
notre déficit de compétitivité ne cesse
de se creuser comme vous l'avez souligné
monsieur le ministre il faut plus que
jamais inciter les entreprises à
investir en particulier dans le domaine
de la recherche les efforts
considérables entrepris pour tendre à
l'équilibre dans le cadre de la
programmation triénale me conduisent à
voter le budget pour l'année 2011 mais
les plus grands défis budgétaires
restent à venir je serai vigilant comme
l'ensemble de mes collègues du RDSE sur
les travaux préparatoires à la réforme
de la fiscalité en recevant son prix
Nobel d'économie Maurice Alley dont la
disparition comme souvent en de
pareilles circonstances a marquer un
reget d'intérêt pour les théories
économiques qu'il avait conçu déclarait
que dans ces domaines de compétences il
s'était libéré des conceptions actuelles
ouvert des voies origin
etoser de nouvelles
perspectives monsieur le ministre faites
preuve avant tout de courage mais aussi
suivez cette économiste éclairé faites
preuve d'audace et d'imagination en
matière de politique budgétaire et vous
aurez notre
soutien merci mon cher
collègue la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur
thierryou groupe communiste républicain
citoyen sénateur du Parti de Gauche pour
10 minutes
avez la parole bien monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues comment renforcer notre
compétitivité sans parler de notre
fiscalité
elle est un cheedduf de complexité au
point d'en affecter l'efficacité et même
l'équité nous devons continuer à agir en
nous tenant à trois principes la
fiscalité doit servir notre
compétitivité la fiscalité doit
rechercher la justice la fiscalité doit
être lisible et donc aussi
possible c'est le premier ministre le 24
novembre qui a dit cela il sera créé un
nouvel impôt sur le patrimoine fondé sur
un principe au lieu de taxer le
patrimoine en tant que tel il s'agira de
taxer les revenus du patrimoine et les
plusvalu du patrimoine c'est le
président de la République le 15
novembre qui a dit cela alors sous de
tel aospic l'impression qui pourrait
rester et que cette o de finance ne
serait juste qu'un texte transitoire sur
le long et nécessaire chemin de la
réduction des déficits et de la dette et
ce alors même que la crise de l'euro
s'approfondit avec la situation de
l'Irlande et d'ailleurs à ce sujet
monsieur le ministre vous vous vous
refuser au motif de ne pas exciter les
marchés financiers à organiser dans
notre assemblée un débat parlementaire
sur le sujet comme nous l'avons demandé
mais alors pourquoi ce record de plus de
1000 amendement et pourquoi encore ces
amendements gouvernementaux de dernière
minute remettant en cause ceux qui
venaient à peine d'être débattu
notamment en usant et abusant de la
seconde délibération en fait ce budget
2011 est un budget de droite et le sens
de la justice fiscale proclamé par
François Fillon s'arrête là où commence
de s'exprimer les intérêts particuliers
vos intérêts particuliers
qui ont mis en commandite depuis
maintenant plusieurs décennies les
politiques publiques et ceux qui les
mènent suppression du bouclier fiscal
pouvant rapporter monsieur le ministre
700 millions d'euros ce n'est pas le
moment remise en cause de la niche Copé
permettant au plus grands groupes de
réaliser des raides boursiers sans payer
d'impôt ce qui rendrait d'ailleurs 6
milliards d'euros au budget pas question
ce serait à la compétitivité de notre
économie avez-vous dit Haus de l'impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune qui
s'enniche rapporterait 1,2 milliards de
plus mais ce serait incité à
l'expatriation des créateurs de richesse
ce qui pour vous désigne uniquement les
chefs d'entreprise alors à croire que
les usines tournent sans salariés et que
le capital s'accumule spontanément alors
réglementer les prix de transfert
aujourd'h ourdi des milliards perdus
utilisés par les groupes pour baisser
leurs impôts en délocalisant la valeur
ajoutée et les profits ce serait
soi-disant s'ingérer dans la gestion des
entreprises et prendre le risque des
plans sociaux et des licenciements comme
s'il n'y avait déjà pas de plans sociaux
dans la France de Nicolas Sarkozi le
président de la République n'est plus
celui du pouvoir d'achat de 2007 il est
le président de 4 millions de chemur en
2010 et puis vous l'avez bien aidé en
cela et puis en même temps je vis parler
de la discussion sur les finances
locales qui a d'ailleurs montré que la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
pose aujourd'hui bien plus de problèmes
qu'elle n'en a résolu mais à quoi chers
collègues ont donc servi les 12
milliards et demi d'euros de déficit et
de dettes supplémentaire que l'État a
engagé pour gager la suppression de la
taxe professionnelle on pourrait dire
12,5 milliards de taxes professionnelles
enlevé création de l'emploi zéro alors à
réduire l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités au 6 milliards d'euros de
la cotisation foncière au gel pour 3 ans
des dotations au collectivités et enfin
à la hausse de la taxe d'habitation de
la taxe foncière ou la la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères ce
cadeau de la taxe prof
ce sont chers collègues les populations
qui le PAI et qui le PAI au MDEF ce MDEF
que vous soutenez ici sur la droite vous
le savez vous le savez cela fera plus
d'impôt locaux et moins de servic rendus
le moins de service c'est aussi vrai
pour l'État puisque la suppression de
milliers de postees d'enseignants de
policiers d'agents des impôts et j'en
passe ce n'est rien d'
que la hausse des impôts mais des impôts
déguisés en réduction en réduction de la
dépense publique payz autant payer donc
autant pour moins de service c'est payer
plus cher ce qui reste notre fiscalité
est complexe disait le Premier ministre
le 24 novembre dernier il est vrai que
si vous cherchez de quoi réduire les
déficit peut-être pouvezvous trouver
quelques outils dans les 82 ou
4 milliards engloutis dans les
remboursements et dégrèvements ou encore
dans les 172 milliards de cadeaux
fiscaux et sociaux aux entreprises que
vous votez en permanence 172 milliards
mes chers collègues c'est l'exacte
l'exacte somme du déficit de l'État et
du déficit de la Sécurité sociale alors
vous cherchez 172 millions c'est pas
compliqué éviteer de détaxer et et on
peut les trouver voilà voilà mes chers
collègues de quoi tenir vos engagements
européens et voilà comment les
dérogations de principe de l'impôt
conduisent au déficit et en même temps à
l'endettement parce que parce que je
dirais que ça fait des années que cela
dure et des années que le moins d'impôt
et le moins de cotisation sociale se
traduit par plus de travail précaire et
par plus de chômage et là encore ce sont
les plus riches
les plus grands groupes qui captent
l'essentiel des cadeaux fiscaux réduire
l'impôt sur les sociétés des plus grands
groupes coûte 60 milliards d'euros
autant autant mes chers collègues que le
budget de l'éducation mais pour quel
résultat pour que Total par exemple pour
ne citer que cet exemple investisse en
Birmanie sans se soucier des droits de
l'homme et que Renault fasse monter ses
voitures en Slovénie ou en en Turquie
tout en annonçant un plan de départ de
3000 départs à la retraite à 58
ans maintenant maintenant monsieur le
rapporteur général pour le sectarisme
vous me donnerez pas de leçon parce que
je vous ai vu à l'vre il y a quelques
instants en commission des finances où
c'était le dictat sur la deuxème
délibération auprès de vos élus pour
voter la deuxè délibération alors qu' ne
partageit pas l'histoire des 15 points
maintenant mais on est pu pour le
centralisme démocratique monsieur le
rapporteur général réviser réviser
révisez vos leçons
maintenant et on on s'est aperçu que ce
n'était pas bon on est pu pour le
centralisme
démocratique c'est de vot côté le
sectaris maintenant maintenant quelques
remarques sur la chasse au niches
annoncé annoncé comme déterminante cette
année un effort sur les plusvalues 1% de
de plus parce qu'il fallait éviter que
seul les salariés paient le prix de la
réforme des retraites pour le reste
bouclier fiscal investissement capital
investissement dans le logement locatif
exonération des plus-values des groupes
régime des sociétés mares dispositif ISF
PME régime des donations et j'en passe
pas pas aucun changement par contre on
va taxer les quelques euros de
dividendes de la participation et nous
avons appris
que le mariage et Pax ét porteur des fa
d' nous qui croyons naïvement qu'on se
marie ou qu'on se paxe par amour voilà
qu'on va aller raquetter 500 millions
d'euros dans les corbeilles de mariage
en faisant disparaître la triple la
triple
déclaration alors pour compléter on a
décidé de taxer les les couvertures
maladie mutualistes et on a la TVA sur
les offres internet téléphone et
télévision sans oublier le droit d'accès
à l'aide médical
ou la ponction sur les organismes HLM
faute de financement budgétaire direct
c'est-à-dire qu'on aura pris dans la
poche des pauvres dans la poche des gens
modestes des class moyennes ce que vous
refusez toujours pour le moment à exiger
des plus riches et des plus grands
groupes ement voilà mes chers collègues
la France n'est pas seulement 240
entreprises et 600 contribuables de
l'ISF c'est près de 3 millions
d'entreprises et 36 millions de redevabl
de l'impôt sur le
revenu alors illustrant d'une certaine
manière cette vision tronquée des
priorités deux exemples qui ont fait
polémique l'un c'est la suppression de
l'article prévoyant de faire cotiser à
l'impôt à partir d'un million d'euros
l'indemnisation au préjudice moral
ainsi après avoir taxé l'aide
juridictionnelle pour moins de 9 € de
l'URE on continue d'exempter 10 20 ou
200 millions d'euros reçus en préjudice
moral par un industriel quelconque
posons la question un préjudice moral
a-t-il une valeur comptable monétaire ce
qui est honteux c'est d'accepter de
marchander son intégrité morale et
encore plus honteux de voir des
parlementaires pour valider l'exemption
fiscale le second exemple c'est
l'article 90 du projet de loi qui
voulait revenir sur l'exonération de
cotisation sociale des employeurs de
salarié à domicile une une exonération
qui comme toutes les autres tant àtirer
les salaires vers le bas et qui couvre
plus des métiers bien différents pour
une urse d'enfants ou l'auxiliaire de
vie d'une personne âgée cela peut se
comprendre mais pour permettre à
certains de se payer des vallées des
vallées de pied des hommes à tout faire
et des gardiens de villas sur la Côte
d'Azur ou en Corse est-ce logique en
matière fiscale malheureusement c'est
souvent
ainsi peut-être je pourrais encore vous
puis je vais terminer vous citer le plus
gros chèque du bouclier fiscal n'a-t-il
pas été remis d'ailleurs à Madame B
encour dont il est évident qu'elle a
fraudé le fisque sur la nature de ses
revenus et sur la réalité de son
patrimoine alors cette to fimance de
transition
préser privilg des privilég et continue
deapper les plus modestes et les couches
moyennes prolong en même temps les
politiques de
2002 j'en mes conclusions monsieur le
rapporte la se des Français sera de vous
présenter la facture à payer et j'espère
que ce jour ne sera pas
lointain en attendant en attendant je
vous ai dit qu'on ne voterait pas cette
loi de finances et qu'il me soit permis
à mon tour de remercier le personnel du
Sénat
merci mes chers collègues avant de
donner la parole au président Longuet
pour le groupe de l'Union pour un
mouvement
populaire je vous rappelle que le
scrutin pour l'élection du ceur du Sénat
sera clos dans un quart d'heure ceux qui
n'auraient pas voté et ce sera à la fin
monsieur le Président voilà donc n'aurit
pas voté peuvent le faire salle des
conférences vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président loguer bien monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues parler en 10 minutes au nom
d'un groupe aussi important dans la
richesse la diversité et la compétence
l'engagement et l'application dans le
débat budgétaire on forcé j'en suis
persuadé monsieur le ministre votre
intérêt et ont soutenu les travaux du
président de la commission des finances
et du rapporteur général est une gagure
que je suis absolument incapable de
relever c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous livrerai quelques sentiments
personnels en vous demandant de bien
vouloir d'une part les écouter et
peut-être pour certains de bien vouloir
les partager il se trouve que nous avons
bénéficié d'un nouveau Premier ministre
qui était assez proche de l'ancien
d'ailleurs au moment au milieu du débat
budgétaire et donc de cette majorité a
acclamé je crois même debout un
programme extrêmement courageux
responsable monsieur le ministre de
votre patron François Fillon et ce
programme nous incitait à maîtriser la
dépense publique à faire à faire en
sorte à faire en sorte que les impôts
naugmentent pas qu'il y ait un
endettement maîtrisé et que nous ne
puissions pas évidemment tabler comme
d'autres gouvernements l'avaient fait
par le passé
sur la solution de l'inflation solution
de facilité qui appauvrit les Français
mais qui parfois s'auvre les comptes et
bien la réussite de ce groupe est
d'avoir tenu par ses votes son
comportement et ses engagements les
orientation que le premier ministre nous
proposait alors que la tentation est
évidemment permanente chez chacun
d'entre nous au regard de l'intérêt que
nous portons sur les innombrables
actions de nos compatriotes votre
administration au service de la France
tout entière d'apporter des soutiens en
un mot nous avons maintenu l'équilibre
malgré la tentation de faire plus et
mieux cela n'était pas possible ceux qui
ont acclamé le Premier ministre l'ont
soutenu par leur comportement tout au
long de l'examen du budget je voulais le
rappeler puisque nous terminons à 91
milliards 645 millions de déficit nous
nous avons augmenté de 25 millions pour
3 semaines de débat avouez monsieur le
ministre que c'est un effort raisonnable
pour autant pouvons-nous être rassuré je
ne le pense pas je ne le pense pas parce
que ce débat fait apparaître et je serai
plus grave fait apparaître avec force un
certain nombre de limites et d'abord des
limites dans la maîtrise budgétaire que
vous nous proposez première limite la
RGPP est le nonremplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux euh le l'examen
du premier budget civil en terme
d'effectif celui de l'enseignement
scolaire montre que nous pouvons à la
fois diminuer le nombre de
fonctionnaires de l'État sans pour
autant diminuer ou d'une façon
totalement marginal le budget de
fonctionnement sur le titre salaire et
nous avons donc là une question qui
double premièrement l'impact de cette
politique deuxièmement ne serons-nous
pas conduit ministère par ministère à
réexaminer l'offre de ces
administrations car il ne sera sans
doute plus possible de faire la même
chose avec des effectifs qu'en effet
vous avez raison monsieur le ministre il
faut ramener dans des normes européennes
que nous avions largement dépassé c'est
un premier exemple je voudrais évoquer
un deuxième exemple celui du rabau des
niches de la dépense fiscale pour
l'essentiel nous nous sommes
efforcés de maintenir cell des niches
dont nous avions le sentiment qu'elles
étaient les plus porteuses pour l'avenir
de notre économie le crédit
impôrecherche et en particulier pour les
PME j'ajoute
également mais très très rapid l'ISF PME
ce qu'on appelle l'ISF PME nous avons
fait les propositions vous les avez
accepté les efforts les dépenses
fiscales ont été réduites elles ont été
réduite raisonnablement pour ne pas
compromettre des politiques de soutien à
la recherche ou à l'Invest ement dans
les PME pour autant l'exemple de
l'article 10 et je 90 pardon et je pense
que vous aurez à cœur d'apaiser nos
collègues qui ont voté par solidarité la
deuxème délibération mais qui se pose
encore des questions sur le
fonctionnement exact de cet article 90
cette niche que vous avez dénoncé et que
vous nous proposez de retirer mérite une
explication plus grande encore on voit
bien que le la de réduction la RGPP au
sens large le rabotage des niches ne
peut plus désormais s'exonérer d'un
réexamen de l'offre de l'action publique
dans tel ou tel domaine fussent au prix
d'une certaine instabilité je voudrais
évoquer dans cette politique de de
maîtrise de la dépense publique deux
autres aspects notre rapporteur du
budget du travail et de l'emploi Serge
d'assau a évoqué le problème des 35 heur
certes et le ministre du Travail l'a
rappelé hier matin encore à France
interre certes nous avons libéré la
capacité de travail nous avons fait
sauter des blocages absurdes et nous
avons encouragé ce qui en période de
conjoncture incertaine est assurément la
meilleure réponse aux besoins d'emploi
nous avons libéré et facilité les heures
supplémentaires pour autant les
contribuables français ont la
particularité c'est sans doute les seuls
en Europe de consacrer plus de 22
milliards d'euros au financement du
travail qu'il bénéfice aux entreprises
que ce financement bénéficie aux
employeurs qu'il bénéficie au aux
employés qu'il bénéficie d'une autre
certaine façon au consommateurs dont les
coûts sont ainsi allégés force de
reconnaître que le contribuable paye le
non travail c'est une situation qui ne
pourra pas indéfiniment durer et je
pense qu'un gouvernement courageux
devrait avoir dans le temps dans la
durée dans la mesure dans la S sérénité
et bien organiser un un rendez-vous où
l'on se pose cette question et l'on se
dise nous avons l'intention d'en sortir
et c'est en tous les cas personnellement
un vœu largement partagé au sein du
groupe UMP je voudrais enfin évoquer une
dernière stabilisation une dernière
maîtrise c'est ce sont les transferts de
l'État aux collectivités locales je
m'expliquerai je m'exprimerai à cet
instant comme ancien président de Région
attaché à la vie locale attaché à la
décentralisation et qui considère qu'en
effet la France est riche de ces
territoires même si elle n'est pas
seulement l'adition d'une mosaïque il
faut que les collectivités locales
acceptent d'être solidairirees de la
destinée nationale nous avons su les uns
et les autres à droite voilà Gérard
longuel le président du groupe UMP qui
est en train de donner son explication
de vote pour le budget 2011 une séance
d'explication de vote qui va se terminer
dans quelques minutes et donc le vote du
budget va intervenir dans cette fin
d'après-midi on va y revenir bien sûr
tout à l'heure ici en salle des
conférence au Sénat